alors mes chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons ce matin pour selon toute
vraisemblance achever les travaux de
notre commission d'enquête avec ce qui
sera notre 40e et probablement dernière
audition il est normal que nous
confrontions nos réflexions et nos
analyes qui ont eu le temps de s'affiner
au cours des des semaines et des mois à
celle du ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
très vivement de votre présence et
d'avoir répondu ainsi à la voocation de
notre commission d'enquête je ne doute
pas que les les députés ce matin auront
beaucoup de questions à vous poser mais
de manière liminaire et avant de
d'entrer dans dans le vif du sujet je
tiens à informer Mesdames et Messieurs
les les membres de la commission euh
comme l'existence de la commission
d'enquête est limitée à 6 mois il nous
faudra prochainement aussi conclure nos
travaux donc en accord avec le
rapporteur nous avons fixé comme comme
date donc le le 31 octobre donc pour la
Réunion qui nous permettra d'examiner le
le rapport il aura été évidemment mis en
consultation au cours de la semaine
précédente donc ayez bien cela en tête
notez cette information de telle sorte
que évidemment vous puissiez comme le
veut l'usage en prendre connaissance ce
qui aura permis aussi évidemment de
éventuellement de de de nourrir notre
notre réunion à ce sujet en outre comme
je vous l'avais indiqué la semaine
dernière la convocation que nous avions
adressée au mouvement des soulèvements
de la terre c'est heurté à un refus
définitif de comparaître hein donc j'
bien vérifié avec les services de de de
l'administration de l'assemblée que les
documents a été envoyés ils ont bien été
réceptionnés d'ailleurs nous avons eu un
un un retour donc nous sommes une
commission d'enquête c'est donc de la
part des personnes convoquées un délit
de ne pas se présenter devant la
représentation nationale et donc en
accord avec monsieur le rapporteur et
comme m'en charge d'ailleurs
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958 en tant
que président de la commission donc j'ai
décidé de saisir de ces faits l'autorité
judiciaire afin qu'elle fasse respecter
les droits du Parlement comme cela est
prévu et monsieur le rapporteur accepte
de de s'associer à cette à cette
démarche donc un un un courrier partira
euh courrier de césine au procureur de
de la République de de de de Paris voilà
euh alors vous connaissez euh évidemment
l'objet de de la commission d'enquête
monsieur le ministre euh monsieur le
rapporteur vous a fait parvenir euh un
questionnaire euh vous savez aussi que
nous avons d'ors et déjà entendu
plusieurs directeurs de vos
administrations centrales et plusieurs
membres aussi euh du du corps
préfectoral je n'ai donc pas à vous
décrire les manifestations de de ce
printemps les violences qui les ont
émaillé les risques qu'elles ont fait
encourir et aussi les critiques diverses
parfois contradictoires suscité à cette
occasion par l'action des autorités
publiques alors depuis la création de
cette commission nous partageons tous je
crois la volonté de préserver préserver
le droit fondamental de manifester mais
préserver aussi l'intégrité physique des
personnes qu'il s'agisse des
manifestants mais aussi des agents des
des forces de sécurité intérieure
préserver bien entendu aussi euh l'ordre
public et les biens en un mot préserver
l'état de droit et nos libertés
démocratiques qui sont tellement
importante il me revient donc
d'introduire nos échanges comme tout au
long de nos travaux je le ferai en vous
posant deux questions générales qui vous
permettront d'exprimer une position à
titre liminaire ensuite comme le l'usage
évidemment je passerai la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur et puis ensuite
je rappelle aux collègues membres de de
la commission d'enquête euh qu'ils
peuvent évidemment aussi intervenir donc
euh avec ce ce ce temps de de 2 minutes
mais mais encore une fois le l'objectif
est pouvoir faire en sorte que toutes
celles et ceux qui souhaitent évidemment
poser des questions à Monsieur le
Ministre puisse le faire donc monsieur
le ministre en premier lieu nous savons
que le printemps a mis à rue d'épreuvve
les hommes et les femmes de votre
ministère les remerciements républicains
que nous leur adressons à travers vous
pour leur engagement au service de
l'intérêt général sont une évidence
estimez-vous avoir disposé de tous les
moyens nécessaires humains matériels et
budgétaires pour qu'il puisse accomplir
leur mission dans les meilleures
conditions estimez-vous avoir disposé de
tous les moyens nécessaires aussi pour
que les citoyens puissent user de leur
liberté de manifester dans les
meilleures conditions et en second lieu
nous avons consacré beaucoup de temps à
étudier les méthodes des je le mets
entre guillemets black block la présence
des fauteurs de trouble est
malheureusement devenu habituel dans les
manifestations à la fois
quantitativement euh mais aussi de de
manière de de plus en plus récurrente
quasi automatique euh et et donc comment
pensez-vous que nous puissions y
remédier comment d'une part prévenir et
et dissuader et comment d'autre part
sanctionner et éviter les nouvelles
itérations puisque on a vu et si cette
commission d'enquête a été créée c'est
parce que un certain nombre de de de
violences extrêmes ont ont eu lieu au
cours des manifestations donc sans
tarder je vais vous passer la parole
monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés évidemment je je
réponds pardonnez-moi je me rends compte
que j'ai oublié de vous demander de
prêter serement jusqu'à
présent donc c'est vrai V que c'est
c'est un point important donc monsieur
le ministre avant de vous donner la
parole en application de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance numéro 58 ti 1100 du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires je vais
vous demander de prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite à lever la main
droite et à dire je le jure après avoir
activer votre micro je le jure je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre vous
noterez l'impatience
de vous écouter en tout cas je vous je
vous passe la parole merci monsieur le
Président d'abord monsieur le rapporteur
mesames et Messieurs les Députés merci
de de votre invitation votre convocation
j'y réponds bien bien volontiers surtout
avec le temps nécessaire de la réflexion
après les les événements très violents
du printemps prochain qui du printemps
dernier pardon qui j'espère que CIT pas
un
absus qui qui permettent à la fois de
revenir sur les manifestations violente
en
marge de projet de loi d' retraite et
notamment après l'utilisation de
l'article 4 9 àé à 3 donc à partir du du
16 mars mais également de de ce qui
s'est passé à saintsoline euh dans dans
dans une manifestation je mets
évidemment des guillemets rural donc là
on a je crois deux exemples de violence
organisé par des groupuscules qui sont
pas si petits que ça nous le verrons
sans doute et vous le verrez sans doute
dans votre commission d'enquête à la
fois dans le monde urbain et dans le
monde rural peut-être un petit mot
d'introduction répondre à vos questions
rapidement monsieur le Président et
peut-être une présentation très très
rapide du de de de petit dossier qu'on
vous a fait parvenir et qu'on va qu'on
va projeter le le premier point euh
c'est peut-être d'expliquer d'après les
services du ministère de l'intérieur
mais vous avez entendu beaucoup de
directeurs des services de de
renseignement qui travaillent auprès de
moi euh ce que nous pensons de ces
groupuscules qui sont divers qui ne sont
pas organisés au sens sans doute
structurel du terme et lorsqu'ils sont
d'ultra gauche ils n'ont pas la manie
euh de le l'ordre et de l'organisation
que peut avoir l'ultra droite et ce qui
pose sans doute évidemment des des
difficultés pour les services de de
renseignement on constate d'ailleurs
quand on combat l'ultra droite la DGSI
la DRPP voust on du vous le dire les
choses sont plus faciles si je dire
parce que elles sont plus organisées il
y a une hiérarchie il y a souvent des
statuts il y a souvent des financements
il y a un souci de l'ordre qui qui qui
est parfois obsessionnel qui aide les
services de renseignement à à
caractériser ce gropuscule quand il
s'agit d'ultragauche l'organisation
existe mais elle est plus nébuleuse elle
est plus
anarchique donc elle est plus souvent
difficile à caractériser mais pour
autant je crois que les services y
arrivent je voudrais dire qu'évidemment
derrière tout ça il y a une pensée on la
on la connaît souvent une pensée
antiapitaliste
anti-institutionnelle qui remet en cause
profondément les les les principes
républicains qui sont les nôtres veut
dire qu'effectivement ce sont des
personnes qui même si c'est parfois
nébuleux sont organisés et même équipé
nous verrons tout à l'heure et vous avez
sout dû voir queils ont des moyens des
moyens de coordination le fait de
s'habiller en noir pour les black block
par exemple ça peut paraître un détail
mais c'est évidemment très important
mais aussi des moyens technologiques on
l'a vu à saintseline des radios
parallèles et pas simplement des
utilisations d'applications que nous
pourrions tous avoir sur nos téléphones
portables il y a un souci d'organisation
pour prévoir des violences pour pas que
les les les les services de
renseignement ou les forces de l'ORD
puissent les écouter
et puis il y a un certain nombre de de
de règles la
dissimulation ce qui est très différent
des années précédente sans doute dans
les contestations ou dans les
contestations violentes non organisées
une manifestation qui dérive ou spontané
type les émeutes urbaines que nous avons
connu au mois de juin il n'y avait pas
de de d'organisation générale de
dissimulation là il y a une organisation
générale de de dissimulation don
derrière l'anonymat des réseaux sociaux
derrière
évidemment le fait de se cacher
intégralement
et de le faire de manière extrêmement
coordonnée un mode d'action qui est
incontestablement la violence euh la
violence contre les biens et et et donc
après la violence contre les personnes
quand les personnes s'interposent contre
la violence contre les biens et puis
évidemment une coordination qui qui
relève non pas de la stratégie militaire
ce serait excessif il n'y a S doute pas
d'organisation au sens préparé comme le
peuvent le faire les les les militaires
mais il y a une tactique qui ressemble à
une coordination militaire et et
peut-être avec des service peut-être
qu'ils l'ont témoigné comme ça en tout
cas ils le témoignne ainsi dans dans mon
bureau euh parfois et je mets évidemment
des guillemets des généraux des
sousoficiers et puis des des soldats
durant et avec une organisation
hiérarchique dans l'attaque des forces
de l'ordre ou dans l'attaque tel ou tel
bien on le verra notamment à
saintteseline a on a Mme imaginé des
colonnes qui attaquaient ces biens ou
ces personnes je vrais dire de deux
points par ailleurs monsieur le
Président en introduction pour parler
des des forces de l'ordre et et ce qui
m'a beaucoup beaucoup interpellé à la
fois lors des des manifestations des
retraites qui ont pu dégénérer ou cell
autour de de saint-sine et parfois même
si c'est d'une nature extrêmement
différente et on voit qu'il y a pas eu
de lien je reviendrai si vous avez des
questions avec l'ultra gauche l'ultra
droite ou extrêmement peu pendant les
les émotes urbaines du mois de
juinjuillet je je peux constater qu'il y
a deux grands débats médiatiques qui qui
qui sont finalement des débats très
importants pour la société pour le
travail des forces de l'ordre ce qui
répond à partir à vre première question
mais pas simplement le premier c'est que
les biens sont aussi importants que les
personnes je pense qu'il faut bien
comprendre que lorsque les bla blo
lorsque un de personnes dont les
soulèvements de la terre ou une partie
des soulèvements de la terre souhaitent
montrer que leur combat est
légitime je constate qu'ils disent mais
on s'en prend au bien on s'en prend à
telle banque qui était sur tel chemin au
FastFoot du coin au commissariat de
police à l'hôtel de ville au bassines et
et donc finalement pourquoi mettre de la
violence physique des forces de l'ordre
face à des gens qui s'attaquent au bien
puisque finalement c'est nous les forces
de l'ordre qui chercherion le le fait
que les choses se passent très mal
puisque nous interposons physiquement
des gens qui ne veulent s'attaquer qu'à
des biens bon c'est un combat évidemment
vieux comme 1789 que de considérer que
la propriété est quand même un droit
fondamental de l'homme qu'on doit
respecter ce droit propriété et que
évidemment il y a des décisions de
justice qui garantissent ce droit de
propriété évidemment dans le cas
singulièrement de de saint je rappelle
que les forces de l'ordre n'ont pas à
être pour ou contre des bassines ils ont
à appliquer des décisions de justice
quand la justice donne tort à la
construction de bassine nous ne
défendons pas des des lieux qui n'ont
pas eu la préatour de la justice il est
évident chacun sait que dans saint
Soline l'intégralité de la vie
administrative et et juridique a été du
côté de ceux qui étaient propriétaire de
de ces Basine donc il s'agit pas d'un
combat pour compre l'écologie d'un
combat pour compre les bassines les
forces de l'ordre n'ont pas avoir cette
idé là le ministre d'intérieur
d'ailleurs se garderait bien de la voir
il applique des décisions de justice où
il protège des biens et je pense que
dans le débat politique que nous avons
il faut savoir Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur si les forces de
l'ordre sont bien aussi chargé de
protéger les personnes mais aussi les
biens et si les forces de l'ordes sont
chargés de protéger les biens comme
comme si nous n'accepterions pas que les
gens rentraient chez vous pour vous
cambrioler ou pour saccager votre maison
quel quel rôle de policier ou gendarme
vous répondrez je ne viens pas parce que
ce ne sont que des biens vous rendrez
compte si j'arrive et que en plus il y a
le cambriillol ça pourrait mal se passer
vous direz bah oui mais c'est quand même
plutôt votre métier et moi j'ai besoin
de la force publique pour faire entendre
mes droits pour appliquer le droit il y
a derrière les groupes ultraviolents der
les groupes ultraviolents et notamment
d'ultra gauche une volonté de dire il y
a une légitimité à attaquer les biens
parce que ce sont des biens qui ne
correspondent pas à l'esprit que nous
avons de la société de demain pour des
raisons politiques qui sont
compréhensibles le combat démocratique
les élections le combat juridique les
recours devant les tribunaux n'étant pas
assez efficace alors il faut le combat
de la violence et les forces de l'ordre
n'ont pas à s'interposer face à ce
combat politique et idéologique puisque
ce ne sont que des biens et en fait ce
qu'on me reproche ce qu'on m'a reproché
dans saint-seline par exemple c'est
d'avoir mis des gendarmes en face des
bassines j'ai entendu des discours
politiques y compris de parlementaires
m'expliquant que si nous n'avions pas
mis des forces de l'ORD face aux
bassines il se serait rien passé on
aurait détruit la bassine et puis c'est
tout il y aurait pas eu de violence il
aurait pas eu de gendarmes blessés il y
aurait pas eu de personne dans dans le
comin alors c'est vrai que si on avait
pas mis les gendarmes à saintseline il
est évident qu'il y aurait eu moins de
violence contre les gendarmes c'est une
toologie je je je l'accepte bien
volontier mais la question de savoir au
parlementaires si on accepte ou pas la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme est-ce
qu'on applique la protection des biens
ou non le deuxième sujet médiatique qui
qui est compliqué sans doute aujourd'hui
dans le débat et que j'essaie de porter
je sais que ça tombe ici essaie de le
porter également c'est que les forces de
l'ordre ont le monopole de la violence
légitime et dans violence légitime il y
a violence et que on équipe les forces
de l'ordre de moyens de violence la
question n'est pas de savoir s'ils ont
ou pas le droit d'utiliser cette
violence ils ont le droit la question
n'est pas de savoir si il y a des
blessés parfois des morts lorsqu'ils
utilisent cette violence dans le cas
d'attentat terroriste il y a notamment
oui quand on rentre dans le Bataclan et
qu'on va utiliser son arme on peut tuer
le terroriste islamiste qui est en face
du policier la question c'est est-ce que
c'est
proportionnel est-ce que les policiers
gendarmes ont utilisé de manière
proportionnelle la violence que vous
leur mettez Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires à disposition et donc
juger la réussite ou pas d'une opération
de police quelle qu'elle soit du
maintien de l'ORD du rétablissement de
l'ordre public d'une attaque terroriste
selon les conséquence le nombre de
blessés et parfois malheureusement le
nombre de morts me paraît être un
mauvais débat médiatique ce qui est
intéressant c'est est-ce que les
policiers gendarmes ont utiliser de
manière proportionnelle la force
légitime que vous leur avez confié pour
faire respecter le droit protéger les
personnes protéger les biens et on peut
évidemment toujours discuter de savoir
quelle est la proportionnalité quelles
sont les armes qu'on utilise queles sont
évidemment la façon dont ils l'ont
utilisé la formation qu' vu ses forces
de l'ordre c'est un débat politique et
médiatique et sans doute d'ailleurs
parfois judiciaire important les
policiers gendarmes ne sont pas en
dehors évidemment de ces enquêtes et de
ces et de de ces procès mais je pense
qu'il faut accepter l'idée que oui de
temps en temps les policiers gendarmes
utilisent la force la violence légitime
pour imposer les règles de droit et donc
le sujet c'est la proportionnalité c'est
pas le fait d'utiliser cette violence
légitime une fois que j'ai dit ça
monsieur le Président pour répondre à
vos deux questions avant la présentation
rapide de
de du diaporama que nous vous avons
préparé qui j'espère éclairera la la la
pensée et la réflexion du ministère de
l'Intérieur d'abord oui je pense que
nous avons eu les moyens nécessaires
euh la la difficulté monsieur le
monsieur le Président c'est la
répétition des événements euh et et on
voit bien que pendant les gilets jaunes
j'étais pas ministre d'intérieur à
l'époque mais également pendant les les
émeutes ou pendant les manifestations
autour des retraites c'est la répétition
dans plusieurs endroits particulier du
territoire euh qui peuvent poser des
questions dans l'organisation des moyens
du ministère de l'Intérieur euh on a
beaucoup fait de progrès depuis les
gilets jaunes notamment en formant à
l'ordre public c'est un métier l'ordre
public c'est pas même chose que la
sécurité publique un certain nombre de
policiers de gendarmes qui étaient dans
des villes certes importantes mais qui
n'avaient pas connu dans les années
précédentes les manifestations violentes
là on voit bien que les manifestations
violentes sont un peu partout donc c'est
la répétition et et la multiplication
des points de confrontation sur le
territoire national qui pose un un sujet
organisation et donc on en a tiré les
conclusions y compris postérieurement à
la loi de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur que la majorité au sens très
large du terme a bien voulu voter c'est
que nous avons imaginé notamment la
façon dont les unités de force mobile
non seulement sont plus nombreuses hein
11 escadron de gendarmerie et de CRS
supplémentairire pour faire de l'ordre
public mais aussi qu'il soit plus mobile
nous prenons évidemment l'exemple de la
crs8 on y reviendra si vous le souhaitez
ou l'exemple des des braves à à Paris
c'est la mob ité qui nous permet de
répondre à la répétition et au plusieurs
points du territoire nous avons en
revanche peut-être en moyen de
renseignement une partie de difficulté
incontestablement nous avons avec la
CNCT c'estàd la commission indépendante
qui procède évidemment aux écoutes ou au
suivi de géolocalisation parfois des
débats pour savoir si la finalité du
renseignement correspond aux personnes
que nous poursuivons voilà avec des
refus et nous le comprenons très bien
mais évidemment ça rend parfois aveugle
et sour une partie des services de
renseignement mais nous respectons le
droit je ne peux qu'insister monsieur le
Président sur l'importance pour les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur de
pouvoir avoir à l'au des nouvelles
technologies à l'au de telgram de signal
de WhatsApp bah la possibilité
d'améliorer notre moyen de connaître ce
qui se passe pour tel ou tel groupuscule
que nous pensons factieux euh les
écoutes téléphoniques à la papa
produisent de moins en moins de
résultats c'estàd quand on les gens
rappellent sur une ligne claire
classique que ce soit d'ailleurs dans la
lutte contre la drogue ce n'est pas
votre sujet aujourd'hui ou que ce soit
dans l'utilisation de cette subversion
violente si les gens honnêtes utilisent
tellégram signal WhatsApp imaginez que
les gens mal honnêtes évidemment ils
vont ils vont davantage et par ailleurs
pendant la période très particulière des
des manifestations contre les retraites
nous n'avions pas les drones
euh ce qui nous a beaucoup handicaper
évidemment euh puisque je rappelais que
seule la police gend Marie ne ne pouvait
pas faire voler de dronees en France
d'illeurs dans dans la sint Soline les
personnes qui avaient des visé violentes
ont utilisé des drones contre les
gendarmes les gendarmes n'aient pas le
droit d'utiliser les drones contre les
personnes violentes bon le Parlement a
réparé cela en vision administrative
nous l'avonsu réussi à obtenir la
possibité de faire voler des drones
d'ailleurs je constate monsieur le
Président que dans la manifestation dite
antipolice absolument ignoble contre les
forces de l'ordre dont on a tout vu les
images de personnes poursuivant la barre
de fer des policiers dans ce véhicule
trois personnes on été interpellé par
grâce au drone c'est un drone de la
préfecture de police qui a pu poursuivre
puisque les personnes étaient à la fois
dissimulé organisé violent et nombreus
poursuivent ces personnes pour qu'ell
soi interpellé d'ailleurs par la brave
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
et présenté devant la justice si nous
n'avions pas eu les drones nous
n'aurions pas pu identifier les
personnes qui ont attaqué ce véhicule de
police qui je crois a choqué l'immense
majorité de de nos concitoyens donc ce
qui nous a manqué à l'époque c'était
aussi non seulement des oreilles mais ça
on a du mal pour l'instant puisqu'on n
pas d'évolution législative à l'obtenir
mais aussi des yeux et notamment les
drones ces drones en tout cas ça c'est
c'est réparé avec l'action que vous avez
bien voulu bien voulu permettre au
ministère de l'Intérieur si je reviens
peut-être à la présentation faisant le
plus rapide possible pour laisser la
place et le temps évidemment à vos
questions euh le bilan des
manifestations chacun les les connaît
votre date du 16 mars si je dire si je
peux me permettre cette ce jugement est
bien choisi on voit que le nombre de
blessés euh à partir du du 23 mars donc
postérieur à à la journée nationale
d'action des syndicats du 8 s'est
transformé après le 493 en une action
violente d'une petite partie une partie
extrêmement violente des personnes
puisque vous aurez constaté que on a
multiplié par 10 le nombre de blessers
chez les forces de l'ordre ce ce
lendemain du 16 mars lors de
manifestation du du 23 mars ou des
manifestations du 23 mars et que les
choses ont continué être un niveau
extrêmement élevé plus de 200 blessés
chez les forces de l'ordre pour
atteindre une journée là aussi également
difficile quoique de toutes petit moins
d'intensité par rapport au 23 mars c'est
du du 1er mai et avec vous l'avez vu une
gradation euh vous constaterez
d'ailleurs que le nombre de blessés chez
les forces de l'ordre en proportion
correspond euh à l'action qu'ils font
pour les interpellations et donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai toujours du mal à
comprendre l'idée que c'est la police
euh ou la gendarmerie qui serait
responsable de ces de ces actions
violentes quand on voit évidemment qu'il
y a une proportionnalité entre les
interpellations euh bien sûr et les
blessés que subissent de force don je
vous remercie de de de vos remerciements
appuyer monsieur le Président euh je
vous avez entendu les les services de
renseignement qui sont venus vous voir
et je pense qu' ils ont pu vous
confirmer ce que les notes de
renseignement remontent au ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai d'ailleurs dit au
président de la commission des lois de
votre assemblée que ces notes
classifiées étaient évidemment à votre
disposition je crois que la commission
d'enquête peut en obtenir un certain
nombre également vous demandz la la
déclassification moi j'y suis absolument
favorable prévoyez en effet la présence
de l'ultra gauche notamment à partir du
mois de la fin du mois de de la fin du
mois de mars euh avec évidemment des des
organisations extrêmement concrètes dans
dans ces violences contre les les
symboles du capitalisme mais aussi des
des forces de l'ordre ou des sites
institutionnel le bilan le bilan vous
vous le vous le connaissez c'est un
bilan extrêmement difficile notamment
1518 policiers blessés et gendarmes
blessés avec plus de 3500 incendies de
voix publiqu ce qui évidemment très très
compliqué mais aussi des élus qui ont
été totalement pris à à parti chacun
s'en rappelle peut-être et et et si je
retire les plaintes qui ont touché bien
sûr les membres du gouvernement il y a
quand même 164 parlementaires qui ont vu
leur permanence saccager pendant C ces
périodes ce qui démontre que à la fois
les parlementaires représent
l'intégralité de du territoire que ça
touchait tout le monde ils ne mourrait
pas tous mais tous étaient frappé et et
particulièrement touchant d'ailleurs je
vis dire une partie ciblée de
politique il y a eu évidemment chez les
parlementaires de la majorité ceux qui
ONU le projet de loi des retraites des
violences plus fortes que que ceux qui
ne qui le soutenz pas alors évidemment
on se rappelle peut-être désormais c'est
peut-être un peu loin mais mais des
difficultés extrêmement fortes que nous
avons eu je rappelle queil y a un
commissariat Lorient qui qui a qui a
brûlé et qui a failli brûler avec les
fonctionnaires de de police à
l'intérieur dans des conditions
extrêmement violentes l'Orient n'est pas
une ville connue pour ses violences
contre la police de temps en temps les
pêcheurs sont vocaux mais mais on peut
pas dire que le commissariat est habitué
à connaître ses attaques Bordeaux chacun
se rappelle la la la la prise à parti
euh de de de de de ce magnifique ara
d'hôtel de ville de de Bordeaux amenant
le maire évidemment à condamner tout
cela et à permettre aux pompiers dans
des c très difficile de sauver l'hôtel
de vî de Bordeaux et puis dans la mairie
Alex du 4e arrondissement de de Lyon
évidemment des dégradations don chacun
se
rappelle alors à Lyon par exemple parce
que faut se rappeler de comment
fonctionnent les choses parce que
évidemment on est un petit peu loin des
images qui sont diffusés par par la
presse là vous avez des des CRS qui
étaient dans dans à l' manifestation qui
était pourtant non autorisée à ce
moment-là on voit bien que les pavés qui
tombent ne sont ne sont pas en
mousse on va
avancer
[Applaudissements]
avance à disjon dans une
[Musique]
ville une rue parallèle qui n'est pas
dans le de la
manifestation vous constaterez que les
secondons pour les retraites ne sont pas
le premier
sujet là je vous rappelle qu'il un
immeuble à prix feu à Paris avec des
familles à l'intérieur oou les pers des
forces de l'ordre sont rentrés à
l'intérieur donc là on voit
les les personnels essayant de
retirer les IM on a mis des poubelles un
imitation en dehors du parcours on a
évacué 23 personnes alors que le feu
prenait dans les dans les
étages et a Saint Soline puisque si on
parle d'autres groupuscules violents et
dans un mode plus rural je rappelle que
de nombreuses dégradations avaient déjà
eu lieu en 2021 au début de l'année 2022
qui faisait certes pas pas écho à des
grands sujets médiatiques don les
préjudices se chiffrai à plusurs
centaines de millions d'euros dont les
personnes sont interpellées et
condamnées par la justice et évidemment
la manifestation la plus importante dit
à Saint Soline
avec quelques milliers de manifestants
dont d'après les service de
renseignement 500 black block et je
voudrais ici de souigner la présence
très importante de personnes étrangères
qui viennent soit dans les
manifestations à Paris mais alors à
saintsine c'était extrêmement
caractérisé on en a évité un certain
nombre puis qu'on a pris ce qu'on
appelle les iat des interdictions
d'entrer sur le territoire notamment
avec nos amis Suisse belge et allemand
mais il une Internationale de l'ultra
gauche qui VI évidemment chacun l'a vu
en Espagne en Italie en Grande-Bretagne
aux Pays-Bas se mêler lorsqu'il y a un
certain nombre de violences organisé et
prévu on a compté jusqu'à 300 activistes
étrangers sur le site de Saint Soline
vous avez évidemment à votre droite les
objets saisis par les les gendarmes les
policiers en amont dans les contrôles
qu'on a pu faire en amont des haches des
cocktails monotop des pics des armes
létales euh et évidemment dans des
conditions euh euh qui n'étaient pas
cell d'une manifestation
écologiste
classique alors pour nous euh c'est
peut-être la réponse principale à votre
question de votre commission d'enquête
ces groupescul violents et leur mode
d'action j'ai essayé de définir euh
représent plusieurs mouvements
politiques euh en tout cas d'idéologie
une mouvance d'ultragauche très très
très ancrée dans la culture de la
violence depuis les années euh 60 on le
sait tous he pas simplement en France
évidemment avec des sujets très forts en
Italie et et en Allemagne une mouvance
ultra jaune qui est peut-être moins
politisé mais qui sans doute attiré un
peu de radicalité des mouvements des
gilets jaunes que je confonds pas avec
les gilets jaunes mais qui sont
qualifiés comme tel par les services de
de renseignement notamment la la DRPP à
Paris les militants sont sont
idéologiquement on pourrait évoquer une
forme de radicalisation et d'une
expérimentation euh d'une expérience par
pardon extrêmement forte d'ailleurs avec
beaucoup de personnes que nous
interpellons qui appartiennent aux
catégories CSP+ de notre peup de notre
notre peuple beaucoup d'avocats il y a
eu des médecins voilà c'est pas
l'ouvrier en colère de l'usine qu'on
ferme hein c'est c'est c'est des gens
qui souvent habitent dans des très beaux
quartiers ont un patrimoine élevé
connaissent parfaitement leurs droits
connaissent d'excellents défenseurs
lorsqu'ils sont mis en garde à vue et
lorsqu'on regarde leur leur pédigré ne
relève pas évidemment du LPLE
prolétariat et puis évidemment pardon se
mê à ça se mêle au désordre des
délinquants opportunistes qui viennent
gonfler si je dire les difficultés avec
les forces de l'ordre donc les groupuscu
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur je pense qu'ils ont un noyau
d'organisation avec des rabifications
étrangères ils ont une pensée politique
idéologique radicale ils ont une
expérience et ils ont des moyens des
moyens dans se seulement intellectuel
des moyens juridiques mais des moyens
techniques do permettre par exemple
d'acheter des radios parallèles dans
l'action des manifestations il
nutilisent pas leur téléphone portable
qui souvent sont éteints d'ailleurs
c'est assez étonnant pour des gens qui
voudraient simplement manifester leur
leurs opinions ils éteignent leur
téléphone portable souvent la veille de
la manifestation il leur allument
souvent le lendemain ce qui est sans
doute peut-être à hasardin mais on
constate que ils nutilisent souvent pas
leur téléphone personnel lors ils sont
dans dans ce genre de manifestation
violentes j'aurais rappelé que 8000
individus font l'objet d'un suivi par
les services de renseignement pour des
raisons de de potentialité d'action
violente c'estd des gens qui ne sont pas
islamistes on parle souvent des fichiers
s islamistes ils sont nombreux je
rappelle que c'est 5300 personnes à peu
près les fichiers s islamistes c'est
3000 les fichiers s d'ultra gauche et
c'est 1300 les fichiers s d'ultra droite
euh alors le fichier s c'est pas
quelqu'un qui commet obligatoirement
personnellement des actes répréhensives
mais c'est quelqu'un qui peut être en
contact ou qui finance ou qui est en
lien extrêmement serré avec un qu'il
pourrait le faire donc je ne dis pas
qu'il y a 3000 personnes d'ultra gauche
qui peuvent passer à l'action je dis
qu'il a 3000 personnes qui sont suivies
par la DGSI au nom de de l'ultra gauche
voilà quand on sait que c'est 5300 pour
les pour les les fichess islamiste c'est
évidemment une proportion importante et
8000 individus en plus suivis par les
service de renseignement donc c'est le
niveau
afférieur les fichiers c'est la dgsci en
dessous c'est la DRPP pour
l'île-de-fance et les territoriaux pour
rest du territoire national ça fait donc
quand même un peu plus d' un peu plus de
10000 personnes qui sont dans la
mouvance que nous connaissons il y a des
gens que nous ne connaissons pas dans la
mouance de de de l'ultra gauche
ultraviolente alors évidemment je je
reviens pas sur le fait que c'est pas
très nouveau hein beaucoup de
mobilisation notamment autour de deux
grands moments qui étaient antérieur à
l'élection du Président de la République
le premier c'est sivin bien sûr avec la
mort de Ry fress et il aussi une
violence extrêmement forte dans les les
les suites autour de Notre-Dame d'And
dans les contestations rurales
extrêmement difficiles et violentes et
puis le le deuxième c'est évidment la
loi travail de madame elcomery qui
chacun se rappelle a créé des mouvements
de de violence extrêmement forts et puis
autour des gilets jaunes même si au
début des manifestations des gilets
jaunes les choses étaient extrêmement
pacifiques parfois une radicalisation
dans certains territoires alors la
France n'est pas le seul pays
concerné je sais pas si votre commission
d'enquête s'intéresse à ce qui se passe
à l'extérieur mais évidemment c'est pas
un sujet propre français on a vu que
c'était pas un sujet propre aux
gendarmes au policiers puisque le rural
comme l'urbain était concerné mais mais
évidemment dans autour des grands
événements internationaux chacun se
rappelle à Rostock à Hambourg à Londres
la mort de de de personnes des des
milliers de blessés les zones à défendre
les fameuses ades sont présentes partout
sur le territoire européen y compris
d'ailleurs dans le territoire sur les
sol des Amérique mais le plus récent que
nous ayons trouvé en janvier 2023 en
Allemagne chacun se rappelle peut-être
une zone à défendre extrêmement forte
puisque il y a eu des tirs de
projectiles et et d'armes contre des des
forces de l'ordre et des blessés très
graves notamment chez les manifestants
je mets des guillemets à manifestants et
en janvier 2023 à Atlanta donc aux
États-Unis il y a une école de police
qui devait se construire il y a une Zade
qui s'est installé et il y a eu des
morts un mort et des blessés il compris
aux États-Unis donc c'est c'est cette
façon de groupuscule de violent de
fonctionner et être organisé touche tout
les sociétés occidentales donc les modes
opératoires j'ai essayé de définir
rapidement tout à l'heure le le le mode
opératoire les black blocks c'est une
forme de de de de franchise hein c'est
c'est c'est on exporte le savoir-faire
des black blocks ça veut pas dire que
chaque fois que les gens agissent comme
le black block ils font partie des black
block qui est évidemment comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure qu chose d'assez nébuleux
qui correspond pas à une organisation
extrêmement physique et concrète comme
peut l'être l'ultra droite qui est plus
obsessionnelle sur l'ordre mais il y a
il y a un recours au mode opératoire qui
est enseigné il y a des camps
d'entraînement par exemple il y a il y a
des tutos sur internet mais il y a sur
notamment sur le Dark web mais mais il y
a aussi des des camp d'entraînement
voilà le le le le le côté renseignement
et surveillance pourche de le détailler
mais évidemment les services sont à
votre disposition pour les pour
l'expliquer ce que N que nous
surveillons pour essayer d'identifier
les les personnes et puis évidemment il
y a aussi une façon d'essayer de
comprendre comment fonctionneent les
forces de l'ordre il y a une stratégie
d'anonomisation je je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure euh il y a aussi une présence
importante de de comment dire
d'homogénéisation des personnes qui font
partie de ce black block par exemple on
évoque
beaucoup dans les services de
renseignement le fait que les les
journalistes qui souhaitent intégré sont
toujours rejetés et violentés on évoque
souvent les les journalistes les
observateurs qui peuvent avoir des
difficultés avec la police gendarmerie
nous essayons d'améliorer évidemment
pour qu'il puissent faire leur travail
dans des conditions évidemment
totalement démocratiques et est
totalement acceptable pour eux vous
constaterez que il y a très très peu de
reportages à l'intérieur du black block
parce que à chaque fois ils sont
découverts menacés et violenté donc
évidemment c'est c'est ça montre que il
n'y a pas totalement d'ouverture
démocratique du du blackloc pardon de de
cette provocation et puis la comp la
complexification du travail des forces
de l'ordre puisque quand on a des
auteurs qui sont très difficiles à
identifier que par ailleurs on agit avec
des gens qui connaissent parfaitement
les qualifications pénales et que il y a
pas de possibilité de désescalade comme
dans une manifestation qui tournerit mal
puisque il y a pas de contact avec le
black block il y a pas un responsable du
black block qui vient discuter avec le
préfet ou avec le commissaire de police
qui est sur place évidemment les les
stratégies des escalades qui
s'appliquent aux manifestations sont
sont évidemment très
difficiles alors parmi les choses qui
qui montrent l'organisation à la fois
intellectuelle et et pratique voici un
un tracte qui a été
distribuer la veille de de sainte Soline
à des milliers d'exemplaires donc il
faut trouver un imprimeur il faut
trouver un graphiste qui fait des jolis
dessins il faut trouver des des choses
un peu peu pédagogiques on vous explique
comment ça se passe alors si vous êtes
blessé surtout pas avoir un médecin un
vrai médecin faut faut faut voir un
médecin un médiic street hein ou un
médique rural en l'occurrence il faut
surtout n'avoir pas son téléphone
portable pas de pied identité il faut il
y a des numéros d'avocat à appeler hein
il y a il y a qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire
au au policiers notamment rien on doit
rien dire au policiers Rien à déclarer
voilà donc ça devrait quand même nous
interpeller toutes et tous de voir que
ce genre de de document il faut des
moyens chacun c'est fonctionner dans sa
vie politique faire un tract en couleur
le distribuer c'est pas si facile que ça
il faut évidemment réfléchir et et les
conseils juridiques et et médicaux sont
sont à la fois dangereux et et
évidemment extrêmement bien bien fait et
démontre bien sûr l'organisation
malfaisante de de des événements et
notamment à notamment à
saintselineon à saintsine chacun se se
rappelle queil y avait de tout à Saint
Soline il y avait évidemment des gens
qui étaient extrêmement violents il y
avait des étrangers qui étaient venus
pour se nouer à l'ultragauche ou aux
écologistes radicaux et il y avait des
gens qui avaient profondément envie de
de
manifester
pacifiquement cependant devant les
difficultés que nous que nous
connaissons arrivé devant les les
gendarmes dans une manifestation qui je
rappelle a été interdite hein par non
seulement la préfette mais aussi par
toutes les juridictions on a eu ce genre
de chose don vous vous rappelez sans
doute
voilà donc ça ce sont des des vrais
pavés donc il faut quand même on est
dans un champ qui n il n'y a pas de pavé
hein donc il a fallu les importer il
Savit hein voilà des cocktails molotophe
je rappelle que les gens ont fait des
kilomètres les gens ont fait des
kilomètres à pied pour être confrontés
au au gendarme donc là vous êtes à
l'intérieur d'un véhicule de gendarmerie
et ça dure pendant plus de 10 minutes
euh évidemment chacun voit qu'il y avait
à la fois des munitions euh et c'était
pas simplement pour manifester en tout
cas pour cette colonne si des
antibassines leur volonté de ne pas voir
construire ces ces
bassines évidemment Notre Dame des
Landes a été une école pour une partie
de de ces militants AG guuéri à des
activités
d'activistes c'est alors l'état euh
essaie de d'améliorer euh la façon don
peut fonctionner mais je voudrais ici
dire monsieur le Président la grande
importance de distinguer ce qui relève
du maintien de l'ordre lorsqu'on fait
des manifestation et qui correspond à
régime juridique et ce qui relève du
rétablissement de l'ordre lorsqu'il y a
des violences urbaines ou des violences
rurales vouloir appliquer les moyens et
les règles pour les forces de l'ordre du
maintien de l'ordre dans une
manifestation à du rétablissement de
l'ordre c'est pas comprendre le travail
des forces de l'ordre et c'est surtout
les privés de rétablir l'ordre donc il y
a ce qui relève manifestations qui
peuvent parfois
dégénérer et dans ces cas-là évidemment
il faut que nous ayons une doctrine
d'ailleurs qui dont les attendus ont été
validé par le Conseil d'État en juin
2021 j'ai été le premier des ministres
de l'Intérieur à proposer un texte écrit
publié d' le premier texte a été retoqué
par le Conseil d'État nous avons
retravaillé validé dans ses attendus par
le Conseil d'État en juin 2021 qui
prévoyait à la fois l'organisation des
des forces de
l'ordre la formation des nouveaux
centres d'entraînement notamment la
difficulté des forcesord c'est qu'il
n'avait que centre d'entraînement de
Saint-Astier en Dordogne pour pouvoir
s'organiser contre le mach l'ordre qui
était souvent rural donc nous avons un
nouveau centre à Villen Saint-George à
la préfecture de police que vous
d'ailleurs voté monsieur le monsieur le
Président dans la lo la lopmie on a
formé l'intégralité du corp préfectoral
qui dirige le maintien de l'ordre qui
était pas fait au maintien de l'ordre et
puis il y a évidemment un certain nombre
de décisions qui ont été prises
notamment la fin des grenades
assordissantees telles qu'elles
existaient auparavant des des on peut
avancer des
des des liens avec la presse notamment
sur la clarification des des sommations
la la la dotation caméra Piedro qui sera
généralisée totalement au 31 décembre de
cette année monsieur de la rue a bien
voulu mener un un débat très long et je
pense un compromis avec l'immense
majorité de la profession journaliste
avec la relation avec les les
journalistes pour qu'il puisse pouvoir
couvrir les
manifestations bref il y a ce qui relève
du match andord dans les manifestations
je rappelle que il y a beaucoup de
choses qui nous permettent de pouvoir
être en intervention proportionnelle
pour pourendre mon introduction lorsque
les choses correspondent pas à des
manifestations d'abord je rappelle que
la participation à une manifestation
interdite n'est n'est pas légale et
qu'elle relève d'une contravention le
fait d'y participer relève d'une
contravention le fait de l'organiser
d'organiser manifestation qui est
interdite ça relève d'un délit
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
et entendre qui est puni par la loi
article 4319 euh de 6 mois
d'emprisonnement donc il y a ceux qui
participent à une manifestation euh qui
est interdite c'est de la contravention
mais donc ce n'est pas euh autorisé et
puis à celui qui l'organise ou qui
participe à son organisation c'est
évidemment un délit condamné euh par de
lamament de la peine de prison
participer à un attroupement
c'est-à-dire une manifestation qui par
exemple n'est pas autorisée ou en marge
de la manifestation après lesommation
qui dit cette manifestation est est
finie ou dans des rues parallèles qui ne
font pas partie du parcours de
ifestation je rappelle que c'est
durement prévu comme étant sanctionné
par le législateur puisque c'est jusqu'à
3 ans d'emprisonnement et 45000 €
d'amende le fait de dissimuler son
visage ce qui arrive évidemment dans ces
manifestations qu'elle soit déclarée ou
non je rappelle que c'est 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et 75000 € d'amende le
fait de détruire des biens c'est jusqu'à
10 ans de d'emprisonnement et on peut
aller jusqu'à 20 ans si lorsque c'est
commis en bande organisée donc les biens
sont particulièrement protégés par le
droit voulu par les parlementaires TER
et évidemment avir des violences contre
les forces de l'ordre c'est entre 3 ans
de prison jusqu'à évidemment des peines
plus graves si elles entraînent not mort
donc une manifestation interdite une
manifestation qui dégénère dans la
violence des personnes qui dissimilent
leur visage qui s'attaquent au bien tout
ce que nous voyons habituellement et
dont on se demande si les forces de
l'ORD on bien fait d'intervenir tout
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
vous qui votez la loi et dont vous
chargez les ministres notamment minist
intérieur de les appliquer ben tout ça
est prévu comme étant évidemment
répréhensible et être présenté devant
l'autorité
judiciaire alors je je reviens très
rapidement sur les moyens qu'on a évoqué
monsieur le Président sur votre question
donc ces moyens sont importants il vut
continuer être extrêmement important je
rappelle que sur les SEP escadrons de
gendarmerie mobile que vous avez voté 3
et demi sont déjà aujourd'hui
opérationnels sur les quatre CRS l'une a
été mis en place les trois autres seront
en novembre prochain et nous avons
évidemment renouvelé énormément de de
moyens je vais pas y revenir et
notamment sur des
drones
je rappelle aussi la loi qui a évolué
notamment la loi dite séparatiste
puisque dans la loi séparatisme il n'y
avait pas que des questions qui toucher
le les religions qui pouvaient se
transformer en radicalisation mais
évidemment il y a des mouvements
idéologiques de radicalisation et
notamment la possibilité de diss
solution dont la loi a souhaité pouvoir
étendre dans le code de sécurité
intérieure la possibilité on y reviendra
et puis nous avons aussi des des
fonctionnements différents au ministère
d'intérieur notamment la création au
sein de la Phi la le ministère
évidemment le ministère des libertés
publiques il a S à une direction très
importante qui lephi qui permet
aujourd'hui postérieur à à à sainsine
d'aider les préfets et les sous-préfets
dans une cellule qu'on a appelé antisade
pour faire une guerre juridique euh
notamment vous savez il y a une
trentaines de projets aujourd'hui des
constructions d'autoroutes des
constructions d'aéroport des
constructions de LGV des bassines qui
sont l'objet de possibles ades euh ou de
ades qui pourraient s'installer on a
l'exemple par exemple castre et Toulouse
en ce moment
alors ces mesures est-ce qu'elles ont
été efficaces ben je je le pense je
rappelle que nous avons dissous 44
associations groupements de Faé depuis
2012 dont
ne9 depuis la loi du 24 août 2021 donc
la loi séparatisme a fonctionné et 666
pardon pour le chiffre diabolique
d'interdiction administrative du
territoire fait par la DGSI pour les
gens qui sont étrangers et qui viendrait
participer à des actions violentes
évidemment en France alors parmi les les
les dissolutions il y a c'est très
partagé entre l'extrême droite l'ultra
droite et l'ultra gauche on pense au Zav
de de Paris au bloc Lurin euh à Bordeaux
nationaliste par exemple mais il y en a
évidemment d'autres que vous avez suivi
bien
évidemment voilà monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur euh ce que je
pouvais vous dire en en quelques mots en
essayant d'être le plus complet possible
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
simplement une une question par rapport
à à ce que vous venez de nous nous
indiquer euh à plusieurs reprises ont
été mentionné le fait que pour un
certain nombre de ces groupuscules
violents il existait des des des camps
d'entraînement vous avez vous-même fait
référence ce matin au fait que certains
d'entre eux avaient tout de même même
s'il s'agissait d'une nébuleuse il y
avait un noyau des rameau des moyens
juridiques et et et techniques euh
est-ce que le ministère de l'Intérieur a
a d'ors et déjà engagé un un certain
nombre d'actions pour euh pour là aussi
euh euh lutter contre contre ce qui en
réalité est évidemment
illégale alors le fait de s'entraîner à
des sports de combat ou à une jouer à la
guerre de une organisation tactique en
soit n'est pas un délit euh n'est pas un
délit pénal euh le fait de le faire dans
le but euh de pouvoir euh euh organiser
le black block de demain euh est
constitutif pour nous euh d'une
préméditation et notamment lorsqu'on va
vers la dissolution de groupuscule euh
ça aide et ça notamment aidé pour
convaincre le Conseil d'État que ce que
nous proposions correspondait à quelque
chose de penser et d'organiser la
difficulté de l'ultragauche c'est que ce
sont des groupement de fait euh
c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
caractériser le fait qu'il y a une
hiérarchie vous pouvez caractériser le
fait qu'il y a une idéologie qu'il y a
des réunions euh mais que tout ça n'est
pas juridiquement installé et et que
cette nébuleuse et demande un très gros
travail de renseignement et de
constitution de dossier avant de
déclencher d'abord la proposition de
dissolution au Conseil des ministre je
rappelle que c'est en conseil des
ministres donc quand le ministre
d'intérieur va dans le conseil des
ministres évidemment un travail qui est
notamment fait par le secrétarat général
du gouvernement on ne présente rien au
conseil ministr sans que le secrétal du
gouvernement y apporte évidemment sa
pierre et sa vision et une forme
d'accord mais évidemment ensuite
contesté par par le par le par le devant
le Conseil d'État ce soit en référé ou
que ce soit au fond donc ça parfois n
nous organisons on la surveillance de de
ces lieux non pas parce que en eux-même
ils portent un certain nombre de
responsabilités factieuse mais parce
qu'ils servent à quelque chose d'autre
parfois ils sont d'ailleurs des lieux
qui servent à plusieurs utilités on
pense par exemple à des stands de tir on
pense par exemple à des clubs d'arts
martiaux ou de certains arts martiaux
par exemple donc les choses ne sont pas
si claires que ça elles ont besoin d'un
travail de renseignement d'écoute
d'infiltration qui prend du temps et qui
parfois ne correspond pas évidemment à
l'actualité le le deuxième sujet c'est
évidemment les les les noyaux des gens
qui ont surveillé c'est pas pour ça
qu'on arrive à avoir des des milliers de
personnes qui sont parfois fichées par
les services de renseignement on essaie
de débloquer un certain nombre de de de
techniques de renseignement qui peuvent
être extrêmement diverse et de
caractériser les choses euh cependant il
ne peut pas y avoir de Minority reporte
dans le droit français avant quelqu'un
est commis quelque chose euh si on veut
en plus que la condamnation soit
sérieuse puisque comme je vous l'ai dit
la difficulté de notre histoire c'est
que ce sont des gens qui sont très bien
intégrés et très bien connectés à la
défense du droit ils utilisent des
méandres du droit pour pouvoir utiliser
de la violence en tout cas limiter les
peines lorsqu'ils sont interpellés euh n
n nous oblige évidemment à pouvoir
caractériser une intention de nuire
extrême et immédiate pour pouvoir faire
par exemple des interpellations avant
qu'ils aillent sur un territoire violent
ou juste après mais évidemment les
renseignements que nous avons nous
arrivons pas toujours à les traduire en
décision de justice puisque il y a
évidemment une vie vous le savez bien
entre la vie administrative du
renseignement et la décision l'dition
judiciaire merci beaucoup je vais passer
la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur merci merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre de
de d'être devant notre commission pour
en
achever les travaux qui se sont déroulés
sur plusieurs mois j' j'entendais
quelques commentaires en apparté de
notre collègue Hugo bernalicis et j'en
profite pour le pour le saluer il pourra
poser des questions dans quelques dans
quelques instants s'interrogeant sur
l'utilité des éléments que vous avez
communiqué à la Commission d'enquête
j'entendais même s'agit-il d'une
conférence de presse bon mais moi je
trouve que c'est ces éléments étaient
fort fort intéressants monsieur le
ministre parce que nous avons entendu la
semaine dernière je crois ou la semaine
précédente
euh l'une des associations les plus en
pointe dans la défense des béas bassines
et qui expliquait que euh au fond euh
les pierres euh sur le terrain de sain
Soline se se prennent à même la terre
parce que le changement climatique a
comment dire entraîné une forme
d'érosion des sols qui font que les
pierres se cueillent comme des fleurs
nous avons vu dans la vidéo c'est pas
tout à fait le cas nous aurons
l'occasion d'en redébattre lorsque je
présenterai le rapport à la fin du mois
d'octobre et de la même façon que euh
les boules de pétant que les les les
Mach
[Musique]
était les Haes n'étent récupéré dans les
coffres que parce que nous avions l'état
maximiser le nombre d'interpellations et
que évidemment on tombe sur des
bûcherons sur des amateurs de de
pétanque provenal ou lonnaise peu
importe au fond la technique employée
non je pense monsieur beralisis mais
vous aurez l'occasion tout à l'heure de
répondre que il était important que la
vision du ministre de l'intérieur soit
communiquée à la Commission d'enquête je
note d'ailleurs que
le nombre d'interpellations ce chiffre
est très intéressant
3339 interpellations entre le 16 mars et
le 3 mai 3339 interpellations nous
sommes sur plusieurs millions de
personnes mobilisées à l'occasion d'un
certain nombre de manifestations je
crois que là cela dénote en tout cas je
ne sais pas si la proportionnalité est
un terme à retenir dans le rapport à
venir mais moins le ciblage qui me
semble exist qui semble formellement
relativement incontestable mais aurons
aurons encore l'occasion bien sûr d'
d'en débattre une question et une seule
pour ce qui me concerne assez général
monsieur le ministreis collègue puisse
vous poser toutes les questions
souhaité au fond est-ce qu'une logique
de désescalade est possible j'entends ce
que ce que vous dites est-ce que le
document présenté il y a quelques
instants pe pas discuter avec des black
blocks évidemment je névoque pas cela
mais au fond
est-ce qu'il ne revient pas je me fais
l'avocat du diable hein monsieur le
ministre est-ce qu'il ne revient pas à
l'état qui a le monopole de la violence
légitime de faire d'une certaine façon
très compliqué le premier pas d'une des
escalades je dis cela parce que à la
suite de l'audition de berar casenu la
semaine dernière qui d'ailleurs donnait
plutôt satisfait site à la gestion du
maintien de l'ordre ça n'est pas pour
autant un soutien politique monsieur le
le ministre je je ne crois pas en tout
cas monsieur banaliss démentira il
considérera que tout cela fait partie
d'un même ensemble politique mais au
fond je pense que cette question
beaucoup de Français se la pose est-ce
qu'une désescalade est aujourd'hui
possible et comment atteindre ce but euh
il y a une inquiétude qui traverse notre
pays sur la résurgence systématique de
phénomène de violence à l'occasion des
manifestations est-ce que ça passe par
des moyens intermédiaires renforcés je
pense notamment au canon ào une des
éléments qui nous ont été communiqués
est-ce qu'il faut employer des forces
non spécialisées dans le maintien de
l'ordre pour renforcer les forces
spécialisées dans le maintien de l'ordre
voilà question très générale monsieur le
ministre je vous en prie Monsieur le
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
euh je pense que tout dépend de quelle
manifestation je m des guillemets vous
parler
euh je je crois pas que ce soit possible
de rentrer dans un système de
désescalade avec ceux qui dans les
manifestations violentes urbaines
euh telle celle que nous avons vécu
pendant les retraites donc les black
blocks pourf très vite pendant les les
manifestations retraite vous avez raison
d'ailleurs souligner que on les confond
absolument pas avec les manifestants et
encore moins avec les syndicats qui nous
appellent d'ailleurs tout le syndicat
confondu quelque soit CELI qui en tête
de cortège pour faire le
précortège différent du cortège je pense
que le préfet de police vous expliquer
ça le travail il est quotidien avec tous
les syndicats avec la CGT il faut quel
que soit celui qui est en tête du
cortège donc vous avez raison de
distinguer discriminer les
interpellations mais je pense que ceux
qui font partie du du black block ça me
paraît très compliqué monsieur le
rapporteur je veux toujours bien parer
sur l'intelligence humaine mais euh
d'imaginer une quelcon desescalades
puisque on voit pas très bien la cause
qui les anime ils ne veulent aucun
contact avec les forcesordes ou avec la
préfecture et et pas du tout avec les
syndicats par je rappelle que les
leaders syndicaux sont eu même insultés
parfois violenté par ces personnes dans
ces dans ses précortèges hein c'est des
gens qui qui mènent la violence pass
simplement contre les forces de l'ordre
ils le font également contre les
représentants de tout système y compris
du système syndical bon
euh je vois pas très bien quel autre
réponse que celle des forces de l'ordre
et de la justice lorsque on a black
block qui veut parler avec personne qui
est extrêmement violent qui s'organise
et qui a une idéologie extrêmement
séparatiste sur l'exemple des
manifestations dit rural elle le fond au
fond euh sur des causes bien identifiées
euh les black blocks je dirais que ils
vont quelque part
pour semer la violence par principe
d'action on voit bien que ceux qui sont
venus à Saint- Soline qui s étaé avec
une idéologie violente ou par une
volonté de manifestation pacifiste il y
a des gens qui ont manifesté
pacifiquement à saint-soline
incontestablement il y a eu quatre
cortèges et je rappelle qu'il y a eu une
manifestation autorisée ce jour-là dans
dans dans la ville elle-même il y a une
manifestation les gens qui voulaiit
manifester contre les bassines malgré
les interdictions euh de la Justice ont
pu le faire dans une manifestation sont
déclaré que la préfette a accompagné et
qui s'est d'ailleurs extrêmement bien
passé au les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants n'ont connu aucune
contestation ceux qui en revanche
venaient pour des causes en l'occurrence
t Lespin ça peut être le cas de
l'autoroute castre Toulouse ça peut être
le cas de la LGV Bordeaux porordo
Toulouse euh je pense que s'il y a des
escalades euh ce n'est pas le jour de la
manifestation les choses manifestement
peuvent se passer puisque ils ont
accepté
de sauter toutes les étapes
démocratiques l'autorisation du préfet
les décisions administratives les
décisions judiciaires y compris
d'ailleurs les les les interdictions de
transport de matériel dangereux on a
quand même arrêté on a quand même on a
quand même pardon
attaqué les interdictions de transporter
des matières ou des armes dangereuses
dans les deux sèves c'estàd que vous
êtesême dans un système de désas qui est
compliqué quand vous contestez même
l'arrêté du préfet qui dit il faut pas
prendre d'armes dans sa voiture bon
c'est je rappelle d'ailleurs que les
associations bien connu ont porté ces
arrêtés c'est quand même un sujet en
revanche en amont et là je pense que on
est on est en dehors de mes compétences
de ministre de l'Intérieur moi je suis
ministre de l'Intérieur voilà mais
ministère de l'écologie ministère de
l'Agriculture j'ai V ministère ministère
du renevau démocratique peut peut être
un endroit de de des discussions sans
doute qui montre que la cause peut-être
entendue en dehors de la violence
peut-être que cela est possible monsieur
le rapporteur mais je suis pas sûr que
ce soit le travail des gendarmes et des
policiers don le travail eux c'est de
maintenir le étblir l'ordre encore une
fois je pense que ce qui est très
important c'est cette distinction je
pense que sinon on comprend pas très
bien ce qu'essaient de faire les forces
de l'ordre entre le maintien de l'ordre
qui est celui qui s'applique à des
manifestations la manifestation en
France vous l'avez défini dans dans dans
la loi il y a des déclarations il y a
des parcours il y a une action et le
réétablissement de l'ordre public où les
gens de manière sauvage essaye d'imposer
des démonstrations qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs des attroupements et
notamment en vue de commettre des
violences et donc je pense que c'est
toujours possible monsieur le rapporteur
lorsqu'on est dans la
manifestation je pense que c'est
extrêmement difficile en tout cas c'est
pas le travail du ministère de
l'intérieur quand on est dans le
réétablissement de l'ordre voilà alors
une fois que je vous ai dit ça je
constate aujourd'hui qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui disent mais quand même à
saint-soline on était venu pacifiquement
et et ça s'est dégradé bon je rappelle
que dans ce que vous avez peut-être dû
voir à saint-soline les gendarmes n'ont
pas bougé de leur
ligne dans dans une manifestation qui
dégénère euh dans les rues de Paris euh
postretraite on peut toujours se poser
la question image à l'appui euh est-ce
que les forces sont bien intervenues
n'ont-ils pas fait de provocation euh
est-ce qu'ils étaient proportionnés
est-ce qu'il fallait utiliser la
mobilité mais à saint-sine il y a il y a
pas de doute monsieur le rapporteur à
saint-sine la consigne des gendarmes
c'était extrêmement clair il euh malgré
l'interdiction de manifestation il
n'intervenait pas lorsque les gens ont
avancé ils n'ont pas jamais avancé euh
contre les colonnes qui arrivaient sur
eux ils ont patiemment reçu des milliers
de pierres de hache de cocktail Molotof
euh avec des ils ont accepté de de de de
prendre sur eux la violence il y aurait
eu beaucoup plus de violence si les
gendarmes avaient répondu euh au aux
dizaines de premières minutes enfin
première heure me semble-t-il de mémoire
dans Saintine et ils n'ont pas bougé de
leur ligne et c'est au contact des des
des des des forces de l'ordre que les
violences légitimes ont pu avoir lieu
pour empêcher évidemment de passer mais
mais euh qu'est-ce que vous voulez
désescalader à ce moment-là à ce
moment-là pardon monsieur le rapporteur
c'est c'est trop tard euh est-ce qu'en
amont parce que il y a sans doute une
nouvelle manifestation qui qui sera
préparée sans doute en début d'année
prochaine euh d'autres ministères
d'autres impétrants peuvent dire bah
voilà comment on peut organiser la
manifestation de votre cause bruyante
euh sans pour aant euh s'en prendre
physiquement aux forces de l'ordre je je
je j'ose espérer que c'est possible en
tout cas je ne pense pas que pendant le
moment de rétablissement de publicique
ce soit possible de la part du préfet ou
la préfette et des policiers des
gendarmes
oui monsieur le rapporteur je vous en
prie juste une une remarque nous sommes
déplacés en effet sur le sur le terrain
pour certains d'entre nous à sainttesine
et nous constatons j'allais dire de
façon presque topographique que s'il y a
affrontement il faut le chercher dans la
mesure où les forces de l'ordre étaient
en effet statique protégeant une
infrastructure et que les distances de
parcours la la géographie elle-même
physiquement pour qu'il y ait
affrontement il fallait ce jour-là en
effet qu'il y ait une volonté de
s'affronter aux forces de l'ordre en
tout cas c'est le constat que nous avons
fait sur place je laisse monsieur le
Président nos collègues poser des
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur donc je je passe déjà la
parole premier qui l'avait demandé
monsieur mendz je vous en prie 2 minutes
merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de tenir c'est 2 minutes c'est
le ministre deintérieur je reviens sur
l'audition de la semaine dernière qui
m'a marqué avec bassine non merci parce
qu'on leur a fait un rappel boule de
pétanque hache cocktail 6 tonnes de de
pierrees en nous expliquant qu'en fait
c'était normal d'avoir ça dans son dans
son véhicule dans son coffre donc essaie
de d'expliquer pourquoi vous avez
contrôlé autant de véhicules et ceux qui
ont été contrôlés est-ce que on a pu
démontrer que la majorité d'entre eux
allent justement à cette manifestation
parce que d'après eux on a contrôlé le
tout venant et même des habitants du
coin qui ne voulaient pas participer à
cette manifestation euh lors des
auditions on nous a parlé beaucoup de de
de choses je je reviendrai pas de
l'autogestion de tous ces sujets euh
mais quoi qu'il arrive c'était la faute
de la police c'est la gendarmerie qui a
décidé d'aller au contact ce ne sont pas
des militants violents ils étaient là
dans un cadre éducatif pour informer et
c'est pour ça qu'il réunissaiit autant
de monde venu de partout en France et en
Europe pour démontrerce que c'était
qu'une bassine et quels étaient les
impacts sur le le le climat et et et
d'un point de vue écologique et la
biodiversité ce ce qui nous intéresse
nous c'est comprendre pourquoi vous avez
envoyé autant de gendarmes si cette
manifestation n'aurait jamais dû être
violente qu'est-ce qui a pu nourrir
vraiment votre réflexion sur le sujet
parce que d'après à les entendre tout
est de la faute de l'organisation du
ministère de l'intérieur de la
gendarmerie et potentiellement des
politiques qui n'ont pas compris leur
objectif euh et nous dire comment vous
avez pu vous rendre compte que cette
manifestation allait finir par dériver
et pourquoi elle a été annulée justement
en amont sur le sujet on a besoin de
plus de détails parce que à les entendre
parler ce sont eux les victimes de
l'État français d'une forme de dictature
et on a besoin de comprendre qu'estce
qui a motivé toute toutes les prises de
position du ministère de l'Intérieur sur
le sujet parce que à les entendre parler
il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu de
violence et même si le cortège était
divisé en trois c'était surtout pas pour
prendre Anton et les gendarmes donc
avoir votre point de vue sur le
sujet monsieur le ministre je vous en
prie d'abord il y a plein de
manifestations
interdites qui au fond à la fin se passe
bien malgré des violences malgré des
autoroutes coupées malgré des trains
arrêtés malgré des entreprises ou des
sites dévastés au sens physique du terme
parce qu'on arrive à anticiper le plus
possible en mettant beaucoup de moyens
je pense que l'une des raisons pour
lesquell les choses se passent le mieux
possible c'est beaucoup de moyens je
prends exemple de manifestation qui a eu
très récemment dans les Alpes notamment
il a aussi une Zade il y a aussi des
endroits difficiles notamment autour de
la clusa pour un certain nombre d'accès
à l'eau qui fait objet de beaucoup de
difficultés sans doute territorial et
beaucoup de confrontations entre les
stations de ski les agriculteurs
les personnes qui contestent ses retenus
et cetera parce que ce qu'on essaie de
faire au maximum pour répondre à votre
question sur S solin c'est d'abord un
avoir des renseignements et les services
de renseignement c'est tout le travail
du ministère d'intérieur son travail
c'est d'essayer de dire ce qui va se
passer combien seront-ils seront-ils
violents y y a-t-il des personnes dont
on sait qui sont les personnes que nous
suivons qui vont y venir et quand vous
savez comme c'était le cas pour
sinteline que vous avez quelques
centaines de personnes à l'étranger
comme en France qui qui vont venir qui
sont fichés vous dites ça va pas
forcément extrêmement bien se passer ils
peuvent d'un seul coup devenir de
gentils agneau mais lorsque l'Allemagne
la Suisse l'Italie l'Espagne
l'Angleterre vous appelle et vous dit on
a des amis qui sont fichés comme
ultraviolent d'ultragauche qui ont déjà
fait des manifestations extrêmement
difficiles extrêmement dures sur le sol
national on vous les signal qu'il on
intention de venir parce que les écoutes
téléphonique ont dit que parce que nos
sources internes ont dit que on sait que
ça va pas être le rendez-vous des
copains de Jean qui donc vous savez déjà
par
indication qu'il va avoir une difficulté
et et donc vous proportionnez vos force
ensuite vous voyez également en source
ouverte comme on dit si les associations
si un nombre de personnes mobilisent
beaucoup ses amis et et si
territorialement ce qui est le cas
d'ailleurs dans l'ouest de la France des
gens se sentent concernés par ce qui se
passe dans le cas de Saintine il y avait
notamment un fait qui nous a alerté un
des agriculteurs
à autorisé l'occupation de son terrain
pour y mettre la fameuse la fameuse tour
donc il y avait une certain nombre de de
coordination qui montrait qu'il y aurait
du monde voilà c'est pour cela que
instruit notamment du fait que des gens
extrêmement violents viendrai que la
préfette des de Sèv et les préfets aux
alentours il y avait même la possibilité
de noria de tracteur qui aurait dû venir
qui finalement ne sont pas venus parce
que pour le coup il y a eu des escalades
et moi je remercie la pré fait d'avoir
discuté notamment avec la Confédération
paysane pour empêcher
que les tracteurs naillent jusque sur le
site donc il y a eu une sorte de
discussion où ils se sont mis d'accord
malgré tout et je remercie la
Confédération paysane de de montrer leur
démonstration de de force pas de le
faire sur le site parce qu'imaginez si
les tracteurs étaient venus sur le site
pour pour taper les gendarmes les choses
auraient été encore plus graves si j'ose
dire et donc ce que nous avons décidé
lorsqu'on a ce genre d'opération alors
là on parle de sa solide mais encore une
fois il y en a des dizaines qui se
passent bien et fort heureusement qu'
font pas naître ni les débats
médiatiques niau commission d'enquête la
proportion de force de l'ordre et et de
nature à à en général euh démontrer que
il n faut pas utiliser la force puisque
nous sommes assez nombreux pour montrer
que le pouvoir si je dire de la force
est du côté des forces de l'ordre la
difficulté de Saint Sololine c'est je
pense qu'il y avait à la fois une
volonté incontestable une partie de ces
personnes de montrer que la violence
permettait de montrer que l'État était
violent donc c'est toute la question de
savoir qui a été violent dans cette
histoire bon moi je pense que évidemment
la violence n'est pas du côté des forces
de l'ordre en tout cas quand ils l'ont
utilisé c'est de manière légitime et
proportionnée c'est ce que je pense
personnellement euh le site ne ressemble
à aucun autre site et ce sont des des
dizaines de kilomètres à couvrir euh
dans des endroits où sans sans sans
urbanité donc c'était quand même
extrêmement compliqué la la les les
multiplicités des endroits étaiibles
parce que il y a la bassine qui est
évoqué mais il y avait plusieurs
bassines comm ça Savion pas quelle
bassine exactement allit être concerné
et les agriculteurs moi je me rappelle
avoir des réunions avec les
représentants agricoles et les élus du
coin expliquant que par ailleurs ils
avaient peur qu'on vienne sanctionner
sctionner des câbles envillir des fermes
détruire un certain nombre
d'installation donc un certain nombre de
renseignements en amont parfois on se
trompe parfois on se trompe pas parfois
on est un peu en dessous bon démontrer
que ça allait pas très bien se passer
euh nous avons été quand même surpris
par l'organisation répétée du fait que
la justice nous donnant raison parce que
parfois la justice nous donne tort mais
là la justice a donné raison sur à peu
près tous les actes de la préfè et des
préfets du territoire à l'exception
encore une fois la Confédération paysane
pour étacteur qu' on a réussi à
désescalader euh que la volonté pour une
partie était de nuir se rajoute à ça le
fait que des politiques monsieur le
député avait dit nombreux qui
viendraient des responsables politiques
nationaux euh des des parlementaires en
écharpe euh qui se sont mis parfois
devant euh des personnes des individus
violents pour se présenter devant le
cordon de gendarmes bon heureusement
j'avais demandé aux gendarmes de filmer
pour pas que parce que je je connais
trop malheureusement désormais
d'expérience le fait que par nature pour
un certain nombre d'hommes femmes
politiques c'est de la faute des
policiers par principe donc désormais
comme des choses sont sont filmées on a
tous pu voir que en l'occurrence pour
cette
parlementaire-ci tout le monde a
démontré que la provocation n'était pas
du côté des gendarmes et d'ailleurs on
en a plus beaucoup entendu parler bon
mais mais il y avait un certain nombre
de faisceaux d'indice monsieur le
députés qui montraiit que ça se
passerait pas bien qu'ils étaient
nombreux qu'il y avait des individus
violents des gens l'étrangers qui
viendraient et que par ailleurs les les
possibilités d'attaque et les et les les
la zone à couvrir méritait une
démonstration très forte des des forces
de l'ordre ah bah après par ailleurs euh
on peut toujours transporter des haches
il y a quand même beaucoup de bûcherons
du coup alors qu' habite sanseline il y
a beaucoup de gens qui qui font des
travaux de terrassement euh il y a
beaucoup de gens qui jouent à la
pétanque et il y a aussi beaucoup de
gens qui font des cocktails Molotov sans
doute pour le pour pour le pour le
plaisir ou transport des bidons d'essens
bon voilà évidemment chacun voit que
tout ça c'est c'est une une douce une
douce parodie la vérité surtout c'est
que c'est pour ça que la préfette et
c'est c'est pour ça que les préfets
prennent des arrêtés d'interdiction de
transport de d'armes ça paraît
totologique mais c'est pour bien
expliquer que ce jour-là à ce moment
précis arrêz qu'on tous était validés
par le juge administratif je je quand
même le rappeler que ce jour-là à des
moments précis on ne peut pas
transporter d'armes et encore une fois
c'est pas une arme qu'on a trouvé c'est
pas un pavé qu'on a trouvé c'est pas une
boules de pétanque qu'on a trouvé voilà
et et pour ceux qui on étent sur le site
ils ont bien vu que les boules de
pétanque ne poussaient pas à l'intérieur
du champ hein c'est un champ classique
comme il y en a beaucoup dans l'ouest de
la France voilà et on avait bien pris
soin d'ailleurs de retirer tous les
travaux qui existaientaravant parce que
parfois dans les manifestations les gens
utilisent dans la violence dans la foule
ce qui se passe là il y avait pas de
travaux à proximité il faut faire des
des kilomètres entiers pour atteindre la
ligée des gendarmes c'est qu'il y a Mme
pas de véhicule on peut même pas ouvrir
son coffre pour retirer dirait ce qu'on
a mis dedans parce qu'on est bûcheron et
que tiens spontanément on a envie de
récupérer sa hache qu'on av mis dans son
dans son coffre il faut prendre sa hache
et il faut traverser et le le le camp d'
mon a vu d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient
organisés ils avaient des boucliers ils
avaient des parapluies il pleuvaient pas
ce jour-là donc les parapluies peut-être
que voilà donc je pense vraiment que
pour une partie des des des
manifestations violentes la
préméditation voilà comme on dit était
caractérisé et je pense qu'il serait bon
de le reconnaître parce que je pense que
la cause euh souvent noble que défendent
les les manifestants quels qu'ils soit
en tout cas tout à fait respectable
évidemment bousculé au fond par la
violence d'unun d'un groupe qui n'est
pas majoritaire sans doute que les gens
violents étaient très minoritaires à
saintseline sur les milliers de
personnes qui étaient là notamment ceux
qui ont manifesté dans les autres
cortèges ou qu'on manifestai dans la
ville mais mais malheureusement les la
les quelques centaines qui étaient très
violents ont transformé me semble-t-il
leur cause en en en attaque contre les
forces de l'ordre et et ne pe pas servi
la cause
écologiste merci beaucoup Monsieur
bernalissis Merci monsieur le
Président dans les 2 minutes qui me sont
imparti je vais quand même revenir un
petit peu sur le les les propos du du du
ministre qui sétonné que les gens
fassent usage de du droit et des droits
qui leur sont dévolués dans le code de
procédure pénale notamment le droit de
garder le le silence j'avais j'avais
l'impression quand il parlait de ceux
qui ont l'habitude d'utiliser tous les
moyens de droit pour se défendre parler
de l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement qui sont mis en cause mais
j'ai dû évidemment me tromper puisque la
suite des propos était assez claire sur
le sur le sur le sujet par contre je
souscris à votre analyse monsieur le
ministre sur le le déficit démocratique
sans doute à un moment donné qui
pourrait combler le fait que on n'
vienne pas à des situations de violence
et on se disait avec mon collègue
Mathieu que que peut-être une
proposition en C fait s'il y avait une
convention citoyenne par exemple sur le
climat qui était organisé et que le
président s'engageait à je sais pas
reprendre toutes les propositions et les
mettre dans la loi peut-être que ce
serait de nature à à faire participer
enfin à participer de la désescalade
voilà c'est une
proposition pour vous monsieur le le
ministre
et pour continuer ma question venir au
fond du sujet notamment sur saintsine
alors vous confondez plusieurs
manifestations et plusieurs événements
et pour votre pour pour la convenance de
votre discours mais c'est pas grave on
va on va pas revenir dans ce niveau de
détail juste à un moment donné vous
dites à Saint Soline il y a pas eu de
provocation les gendarmes ont encaissé
subi pendant des des longues minutes et
longues heures bon alors moyennant les
quad je dire si on met de côté les quad
et le fait que ils aent tiré sur le
mauvais cortège c'est presque vrai tout
ce que vous avez raconté est-ce que du
coup vis-à-vis de C qui ce qui a été
fait par les les gendarmes à ce
moment-là les tirs de LBD sur un cortège
tout à fait Pacifique vous avez dit je
n'ai vu aucune problème de disproportion
d'usage de la force rien rien rien de
problématique à saintsine est-ce que du
coup vous vous continuez à vouloir euh
que les policiers ne puissent pas être
mis en cause et mis en détention
provisoire quand ils commettent des
exactions euh comme ça a été proposé par
le lgpn cet été et est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de faire un projet de loi
qui va en ce sens c'est-à-dire de faire
en sorte que quand les policiers euh
sont mis en cause dans le cadre de leur
fonction pour usage disproportionné de
la force qui ne puisse pas faire l'objet
de mesures euh privatives de de liberté
au moment de de de l'enquête et je
terminerai en disant que quand même
24000 fouilles et à la fin se retrouve
quand même avec des pavés des armes et
cetera mais comment ça se fait monsieur
le ministre c'est c'est c'est c'est
invraissemblable les gens font mal leur
travail qui vous mettez en cause en
disant
ça monsieur le ministre je vous en prie
oui alors Monsieur Beris il y a des
questions qui je crois relèvent pas
tellement de la commission d'enquête
mais je veux bien y répondre par par
principe mais je pense que c'était pas
l'objet de la la commission je regrette
que vous condamniez pas les les violence
une nouvelle fois et que vous les
justifiez même euh non vous Conz
toujours pas les les violences c'est
c'est d'ailleurs dommage parce que parce
que dans des mouvements pacifistes on
semble- qu'on con la violence et je vois
pas le rapport entre la défense du
climat et jeter un cocktail m sur un
gendarme j'ai du mal ou de entre la
défense de
l'écologie la défense de la nature et
envoyer des boules de pétanque à la tête
d'un policier je vois pas trèsement le
rapport vous vous le voyez je suis pas
sûr
que les gens se disent tiens s'il y
avait des propositions la convention
citoyenne reprise dans un Tex de lo on
arrêterait de jeter des haches sur un
sousofficier de la gendarmerie qui est à
terre peut-être que c'est un lien mais
je je me paraît pas évident je pense que
tout le monde y gagnerait monsieur le
député à à dire que la violence c'est
jamais une bonne chose d' me semble-t-il
que la politique c'est c'estessayer
d'avoir dans un débat pacifié non
violent des des discussions qui
auparavant se faisaient de manière
violente mais voilà
euh donc je partage évidemment pasos vos
attendus deuxièmement vous parliez des
quad c'est comme les motos de la brave
les quad c'est la mobilitéord je vous
rappelle que j'ai saisi
l'iggn et que l'iggn rapport est à votre
disposition puisque la vidéo qui a été
démontrée montré le tir à partir du quad
c'est pour ça que j'ai saisi les GGN sur
les deux gendarmes qui ont utilisé ces
tir et démontrer pas ce qui se passait à
côté de la vidéo et c'est dommage parce
que c'est un peu comme la manifestation
à Paris voyez j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
relayer de votre parti politique et sans
doute aussi qui vous sont proches la
vidéo de la voiture de de de police avec
le monsieur qui sort son arme hein et
puis on s'aperçu qu'en fait il 30 avant
alors là on a eu moins de commentaires
parce que là on vous a pas vu condamner
les personnes qui ont tapé à coup de
barre de fer les les les policiers je
rappelle les policiers monsieur
président qui dans ce cas très précis
des manifestations à Paris n'était
n'était pas là pour couvrir la
manifestation il venait d'arrêter un
dealer dans le cas de la Coupe du monde
de rugby puisqueil y avait nos amis
irlandais qui vivaient des vers à la
terrasse de café dans un endroit qui
n'était pas prévu strict sensu pour la
manifestation donc vous voyez ça c'est
typiquement une sorte de manipulation
médiatique très intéressante de la part
notamment de ceux qui n'aiment pas la
police et qui n'aiment pas les policiers
le repr Prochant même de pas assez
contrôler les personnes fin monsieur
Bernad vous souhaitez qu'il ait plus de
contrôle j'entends peut-être il faut-il
à la demande de Monsieur ber faire
davantage de contrôle ils ont fait 6
tonnes de pierres ce jour-là peut-être
que nous devons contrôler davantage les
gens à la demande de Monsieur Bernis je
retiens votre proposition monsieur le
député je constate que dans cette
affaire très précise de la vidéo tronqué
de Paris heureusement il y a eu 30
secondes auparavant qui on été diffusé
il s'agit bien de gens qui n'étaient pas
dans la manifestation qui étaient en
dans la manifestation et qui s'emprenent
à des policiers qui n'encadraient pas la
manifestation mais qui VI d'arrêtter un
dealer voilà donc je pense que Monsieur
le Député quand on dit la vérité on l'a
dit pas à moitié
troisièmement vous m'avez posé la
question finalement de la responsabilité
des forces de l'ordre et de leur lien
avec l'autorité
judiciaire moi je souscris totalement au
propos du directeur général de la police
nationale et du préfet de poli
l'occasion de dire je le
redis il n'a nullement été évoqué et dit
que les policiers des gendarmes à la
demande de leur hiérarchie dont je suis
demander une justice d'exception c'est
tellement vrai que j'ai moi-même proposé
l'aggravation des sanctions contre les
policiers des gendarmes puisque étant
policiers gendarmes portant l'uniforme
de la république ayant la violence
légitime ayant des armes ayant la
contrainte du droit lorsqu'ils
commettent des fautes qui sont
contraires aux règles qui s'appliquent à
tous les Français ils doivent être
davantage sanctionner que les autres
parce qu'ils ont un devoir d'exemplarité
c'est tellement vrai vous le savez très
bien je crois que vousz même ses
dispositions que lorsqu'un policier ou
un gendarme même en dehors de ses
fonctions lorsqu'il est condamné pour
violence conjugale lorsqu'il est
consommateur de drogue et qu'il est
confondu comme tel puisse être non pas
passé dans un conseil discipline ce qui
était le cas auparavant mais purement et
simplement banni de l'uniforme de la
République bon je l'ai fait donc moi je
suis pour l'exemplarité et je suis de
ceux qui disent oui les policiers
gendarmes doivent être condamnés
davantage que le simple citoyen
lorsqu'ils utilisent les moyens qu'on
leur a donné le Parlement à des à
mauvais tion
ensuite je veux dire deux choses il faut
distinguer la faute consciente et la
faute de la vie de tous les jour au sens
oelle n'est pas été faite de manière
consciente bon si je prends l'exemple de
ce qui s'est passé à Marseille qui était
l'objet de la discussion du directeur
général de la police nationale on peut
penser dans le casadre notamment du
policier du raid sans rentrer dans le
secret de l'instruction que ils ont
eux-mêm utilisé des armes intermédiaires
puisque ils ont accepté l'idée de pas
utiliser des armes à feu pour utiliser
d'autres armes intermédiaire acceptant
eux-même parce que vous n'étiez pas là
au début de mon propos monsieur le
député mais j'aimerais i si vous le
rappelez la question n'est pas
l'utilisation de la violence mais la
proportionnalité de l'utilisation de la
violence c'est très différent comme
débat donc il me semble moi que lorsque
des policiers ou des gendarmes utilisent
des armes intermédiaires ils acceptent
déjà l'idée de la proportion est-ce
qu'ensuite cette proportion elle est
juste ou pas juste ça bien sûr que c'est
au juge de le faire peut-être
àinspection générale de la police et de
la gendarmerie en administratif ou en
judiciaire et à la fin à jruction que de
le faire la la question qui se pose
c'est est-ce que le policier et le
gendarme comme tout le monde a le droit
à la présempption d'innocence première
question je pense plutôt que oui et j'ai
même l'impression que le policier
gendarme qui est mis en cause et il peut
être mis en cause personne pense qu'il
ne peut pas être mis en cause il ne do
peut pas être traité comme un délinquant
parce que par ailleurs s'il a des
responsabilité supplémentaire il a aussi
une voix à sarmmenter comme on disait à
l'époque supplémentaire on doit
davantage croire me semble-t-il le
policier de gendarme que le délincant
comme je crois davantage la parole du
professeur que celle de l'élève lorsque
app parent d'élèv dit quelque chose à un
professeur qu le professeur lui dit
écoutez votre fils a fait ça peut-être
que professeur ment mais il y a quand
même à mon avis dès le début quand on
respecte l'autorité d'abord à donner
crédit à la parole du professeur ça veut
pas dire que la parole du professeur
elle mérite d'être acceptée quoi qu'il
arrive ça veut dire que a priorie je
suis plutôt du côté du policier je suis
plutôt du côté du juge je suis plutôt du
côté du professeur voyez je suis plutôt
du côté du maire par exemple lorsqu'il
parle à sa population bon et puis
deuxièmement monsieur le monsieur le
député la question qui se pose c'est la
détention provisoire en effet il y a des
policiers des gendarmes qui sont en
détention provisoire en l'occurrence
pour la police nationale je pense qu'on
en a une vingtaine aujourd'hui il y a
des gens qui méritent totalement y être
bien sûr parce qu'ils sont confondus de
façon évidente parce que les preuves
sont là dans les fait qu'ils ont
déshonoré l'uniforme de la République
ceux qui ont participé à un trafic de
cocaïne en Guyane les policiers adjoints
qui l'ont fait moi je trouve ça très
bien que pour la propre le propre
honneur de la police nationale ayant
aucun doute en attendant leur jugement
mais les faits étant là de manière
incontestable qu'il soit mis en
détention provisoire euh bien évidemment
j'ai jamais demandé que les policiers
GES ne soient pas en revanche quand euh
euh le les les ce qui est prévu dans le
code pénal euh dans le code de procédure
pénale monsieur le député c'est-à-dire
la garantie de représentation la
pression sur les témoins et le fait que
cette personne ne partirait pas à
l'étranger par exemple privant un site
de ses papiers identité un policier un
gendarme dans le cadre de ses fonctions
qui a peut-être utilisé peut-être
peut-être utilisé la force de manière
non conforme euh à la déontologie et et
aux règles bien sûr que le juge doit
juger à la fin doit le sanctionner mais
faut-il pour autant considérer qu'il a
la même place que le délinquant en
prison dont lui n'a pas de garantie de
représentation a envie de faire pression
sur les témoins à une bande organisée
qui peut mettre telle ou telle personne
dans le dans le dans dans le dans le
dans le changement dans la pression
faite devant les magistrats ou peut
partir à l'étranger pour se cacher c'est
pas le cas euh me semble-t-il de
l'immense majorité des policiers et des
gendarmes donc ce que nous disons ce
n'est pas qu'il ne faut pas que les
policiers gendarmes répondent au leur
acte ce n'est pas que les policiers et
les gendarmes euh ne soient pas
condamnés bien évidemment qu'ils doivent
l'être et quand ils le sont parce qu'ils
ont fait des fautes ils doivent être
plus lourdement que n'importe quel
citoyen mais oui a priori il faut
d'abord écouter la parole du policier
plutôt que celle euh euh du du délincant
c'est l'égalité qui qui qui me choque
c'est ce que je pense parce que moi je
suis du côté des policiers et des
gendarmes euh cependant dans ce cas
précis des violences monsieur le
monsieur le le député c'est c'est
dommage de pas vouloir euh pas parler de
manifestations parce que vous avz
beaucoup de choses à dire sur sur sur le
black block et c'est dommage d'ailleurs
que vous ne fassiez pas ce que les
autres camarades de l'anupess ont fait
comme le sénateur Durin qui qui a
beaucoup dénoncé ce que faisait la brave
par exemple et qui a passé une journée
avec la brave moi je vous encourage une
nouvelle fois Monsieur le le député à
venir passer une journée avec les
policiers et les gendarmes parmi eux
avec eux ça veut pas dire que vous serez
d'accord avec eux vous verrez c'est des
pères et mères de famille ils ont envie
que les choses se passent bien vous
verrez la violence qui qu'il subissent
et comme le sénateur dur Rin je pense
que vous changerez alors à ce momentl me
semble-t-il d'opinion sans être tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que je peux
dire
merci c'est la représentation nationale
monsieur je vais passer la parole à
Madame Miller ensuite à Madame Mar et
ensuite à monsieurie iller je vous en
prie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre la
semaine dernière on a auditionné donc
comme on l'a déjà évoqué le collectif
bassine non merci on a été pour certains
d'entre nous assez effaré par ce qu'on a
entendu on a évidemment patiemment
écouté des individus qui étaient sans
doute mus par une extrême motivation en
faveur de la protection de
l'environnement à non pas douter mais
qui par leurs propos nous ont alerté
s'il était encore besoin d'être alerté
sur une tendance dans la société et dans
certains groupes euh écologiste qui est
celle de la désobéissance civile euh
c'est évidemment faut je pense qu'il
faut faut distinguer effectivement deux
deux catégories on a effectivement des
manifestations comme vous l'avez dit
avec des gens qui sont pacifistes qui
viennent pour manifester pour des idées
et qui sont un peu débordés par des
groupuscules violents qui sont
absolument pas là pour la défense d'idée
mais pour casser et on a en revanche là
et on l'a vu avec le l'audition de la
semaine dernière des des manifest enfin
des des des organisateurs de
manifestations qui euh relient
directement la cause à de la violence et
à une volonté de de de de voilà d'être
violent à l'occasion de manifeste de
manifestation on a le porte-parole donc
la semaine dernière qui nous disait je
cite nous nous sommes autorisés à
pratiquer la désobéissance civile ce
dernier estimait d'ailleurs la semaine
dernière encore que c'était vos
arbitrages qui avait conduit à la
violence lors de la manifestation il
allait même jusqu'à suggérer hein de
qualifier les forces de l'ordre de
groupuscule violent euh donc nous
évidemment on croit monsieur le ministre
que transgresser la loi sous prétexte de
l'action enfin que une action serait
légitime c'est un glissement extrêmement
dangereux dans nos démocraties cette
légitimité en effet elle peut évidemment
être prétextée pour n'importe qui et par
n'importe qui par quelqu'un
d'extrêmement pacifiste mais aussi par
des dangereux criminels et comment
est-ce qu'on peut la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on peut gérer cette
inversion des valeurs stopper finalement
cette tendance grave de considérer que
la légitimité la légitimité d'une action
permet de passer outre les lois de la
République et plus précisément est-ce
que vous pensez que l'arsenal juridique
qui a déjà été renforcé par la loi du 24
août 2021 est-ce qu'il est est
finalement suffisant face à cette
radicalité
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre je vous
repasse la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mad la députée j'aiessayé de
d'évoquer deux glissements sémantiques
ou deux inversions de valeur dans mon
propos introductif la proportionnalité
pour l'utilisation de la violence et le
fait que les biens étaient aussi
importants que les personnes à protéger
en tout cas c'est la déclaration droits
de l'homme qui le dit l'ensemble de nos
codes juridique le troisième peut-être
glissement sémantique qui apparaît alors
il apparaît de façon plus minoritaire
mais c'est ce que vous disiez c'est
finalement que il y a de groupes qui
s'opposent il y
aurait des policiers des gendarmes et
puis il y aurait des manifestants et que
finalement on on a qu'à regarder à la
fin don pas qui a gagné c'est pas
l'objet mais mais qui a mal utilisé la
force bonah évidemment je m'inscrire
totalement en faux dans ce glissement
les polici il y a pas deux camp qui
s'opposent il y a des forces de l'ordre
qui sont pas à la police du gouvernement
qui sont à la police nationale ale ou la
gendarmerie nationale qui applique la
loi votée par les parlementaires ou qui
applique les décisions de justice je
rappelle d'ailleurs que lorsque nous
mettons des gens en garde à vue lorsque
les gens sont des prolongements de garde
à vue lorsqu'il y a des contrôles
d'identité c'est toujours sur l'autorité
des magistrats c'est pas sur l'autorité
du ministre de l'Intérieur je ne demande
pas de mettre quelqu'un en garde à vue
ce n'est pas possible je sais que
beaucoup de gens aimeraient que le
ministre de l'Intérieur puisse décider
des arrestations des interpellations des
mises en garde à vue des mises en examen
ce sont des magistrats indépendants qui
le font et ils le font vous l'z
constater de manière extrêmement divers
le procureur de la République à Saint-
Soline comme c'est le cas évidemment à
Paris donc la séparation des pouvoirs
est garantie la police et la gendarmerie
ne sont pas la police la gendarmerie du
ministre mais la police la gendarmerie
qui applique la loi et qui applique les
décisions de justice et donc on ne peut
pas mettre un signe égal entre
manifestant violents et je trouve que
manifestant c'est un mauvais mot mais
entre personnes violentes quelle que
soit leur cause et les forces de l'ordre
parce que ça vousoudrait dire dire en
effet que les règles de la République
qu'elle s'est choisi démocratiquement
sont relatives et sont
interprété et et que en soit la violence
c'est un combat qui permet de leschanger
bon donc moi je crois qu'il y a des
moments qui permettent de changer les
règles démocratiques ça s'appelle les
élections il peut y avoir des des des
actions démocratiques et pacifistes qui
permettent de faire des pressions pour
changer la loi changer la loi c'est ce
que vous faites tous les jours et et on
fait de la politique pour la changer on
considère que l'ordreétabli n'est pas le
bon on se bat pour ça mais indépendment
des élections libres et disputé il y a
un certain nombre d'actions qui sont des
manifestations par exemple pacifistes on
a vu des manifestations nombreuses et
pacifistes changer une loi que ce soit
évidemment dans le domaine sociétal ou
dans le domaine économique donc moi je
pense qu'effectivement ce glissement
sémantique est extrêmement dangereux je
trouve que ce qui est ce qui est
dangereux ça je P ça dépasse le
ministère de l'Intérieur et je peux
rejoindre ce que disait monsieur
bernalicis tout tout à l'heure dans son
propos introductif même s'il le disait
de manière plus provoquante et sans
doute pas pour trouver pas pour trouver
un accord entre nous bon c'est dommage
d'ailleurs c'est
dommage je trouve que il y a il y a il y
a une une aspiration chez une partie de
nos compatriotes qui je pense est
minoritaire mais qui est relayée
médiatiquement et politiquement et qui
est importante pour dire le le combat
démocratique n'est pas suffisant ou en
tout cas il est vissé d'avance et donc
il faut aller vers des actions violentes
pour se faire entendre euh je crois que
c'est c'est en dehors de la façon dont
les policiers gendarmes travaillent je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
devrait tous nous
interroger le fait que ce n'est pas par
des combats démocratiques qu'on arrive à
changer les choses c'est par des combats
violents qu'on arrive à prendre
conscience faire prendre conscience à la
société il il y a eu ce genre déjà
d'expérience notamment par l'ultragauche
en Italie dans les années 70 qui au
début a commencé par des contestations
violes contre les bienens qui s'est
terminé par des assassinats contre des
personnes je dis pas que c'est ce qui se
passera en France je dis que quand on a
de la violence il est difficile ensuite
de de l'arrêter parce que si la violence
contre les biens ne produit pas le
changement attendu et que votre théorie
consiste à dire que la violence peut
faire changer les choses plutôt que la
démocratie alors peut-être que la
violence contre les personnes non pas si
je dire par récocher ce qui est le cas
la violence contre les gendarmes
lorsqu'il protège la bacine de
saint-soline et plutôt les décisions de
justice de saint-sine mais mais comme
vision dire il faut s'attaquer à telle
personne pour pas changer les choses je
pense qu'alors on basculera dans
totalement autre chose donc oui vous
avez raison il y a un inversement euh
sémantique je je je veux répéter hein
moi je pense que cette question des
biens est une question très importante
euh si législateur veut changer les
principes du droit les policiers les
appliqueront mais aujourd'hui les biens
euh quel qu'ils soit sont protégés le
droit de propriété est protégé ce qu'on
a fait à saintsonine c'est qu'on a
souillé on on a euh entacher le droit de
propriété pas simplement des bassines
mais serait-ce que des champs des
agriculteurs on imagine que ces champs
d'agriculteurs qui ont été traversés par
des milliers de manifestants qui ont été
piétinés par des manifestants ils ont
retrouvé pendant des semaines et des
semaines des mortiers des boules de
pétanque des pavés inutilisablebl
pendant plusieurs mois et
personnellement enfin ça n'a choqué
manifestement personne médiatiquement on
a entaché le drit de propriété mais si
le Parlement ou la politique décide que
droit de propriété c'est c'est pas grave
mais il faut dans ces caslà il faut faut
le dire for ils ne font qu'appliquer la
loi bon je crois que beaucoup de gens
considèrent que droit de propriété c'est
un droit de l'homme et que évidemment
ils considèrent tout cela comme étant
positif parce que derrière cette
idéologie Madame La la la députée je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'idéologie
anticapitaliste et antidémocratique sous
prétexte de protéger l'écologie et
notamment chacun sait que pour une
partie de l'ultragauche la propriété
devrait pas exister euh que la com
communautarisation des biens euh
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de de propos
sur ça il faut il y a des biens qui qui
ne méritent pas d'êre propriété c'est
c'est le cas de l'eau c'est le cas bon
c'est une discussion politique et
idéologique mais derrière tout ça ce
sans de ce que pense en partie peut-être
monsieur bernadessis que je vois
n'écoutant pas mes mes contestants je
pense qu'il y a une idéologie qui
consiste à penser que le droit propriété
c'est pas bien voilà et et B voilà donc
c'est une question
fondamentale et la démocratie libérale
et et les élections libres et disputées
et et l'idée que la cause est plus
importante que la démocratie que le que
le choix majoritaire libre est disputé
donc euh à la fin des fins le policier
gendarmes il en vient à appliquer ce que
nous avons décidé depuis 1789 s'il faut
changer des fondements faut juste dire
au policiers au gendarmes ils font ce
qu'on leur demande ils appliqueront le
drit tel que votter par les
parlementaires merci beaucoup madame
arceau merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre euh
nous avons également auditionné dans
notre commission d'enquête monsieur le
l'ancien Premier ministre Bernard casenu
et ce
dernier soutenait lors de cette audition
que l'attitude de la France insoumise à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre n'était
pas responsable je le cite et que
qualifier un ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur d'assassin entre guillemets
sans dénoncer les violences dans les
manifestations était indigne alors selon
vous quel est l'impact des déclarations
et postures de certains responsables
politiques sur l'ampleur des violences
lors des manifestations dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui pensez-vous que les
événements de Saint Soline ou encore par
exemple l'incendie de la mairie de Lyon
pendant les manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites aurait eu lieu
sans certaines déclarations de
responsable politique établissez-vous un
lien direct entre certaines déclarations
politiques et le caractère
insurrectionnel et violent de certains
manifestant vous nous avez d'ailleurs
euh parlé de de de la de la réalité de
l'attitude de certains parlementaires
présents sur site à saintte Soline euh
donc moi j'aimerais bien que vous nous
précisiez euh qui qui ils étaient et
d'ailleurs bassine non merci la semaine
dernière était accompagné d'un d'un
juriste de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme qui nous a remis un rapport et
dans un rapport de différents
observatoires qui géographiquement qui
dépend de la Ligue des droits de l'homme
et en fait il il mettait les photos en
fait des parlementaires en
écharpe clairement dedans donc certains
on les connaît effectivement on le sait
clairement ils nous ont remis
publiquement ce rapport donc moi je
voudrais savoir ce que ce que vous
pensez de tout ça
merci je repasse la parole à Monsieur
ministre de l'Intérieur
euh je crois que la parole publique a
une influence sur les
personnes in contestablement surtout
lorsqu'on est des responsables
politiques candidat élection
présidentielle que des millions de
personnes votent pour vous vous avez
accès à une très large audience je pense
que la responsabilité politique dans
responsable politique et responsable
fait queon sait tous
que la parole au commencement a été le
verbe a une influence sur les personnes
c'est c'est une évidence surtout quand
on a la chance l'honneur d'avoir une
adhésion à sa personne voilà et donc
évidemment les propos les organisations
les slogans les
caricatures les insultes qui peuvent
faire partie du jeu politique et qui
sont parfois excessifs qui ont toujours
existé dans la
République sont d'autant plus
inquiétants lorsqu'ils sont répétés
conscients et et qui dont on voit
quelles sont les causes je trouve que la
manifest
tion dite antipolice organisée par la
France insouise en partie pas simplement
dans laqu j'ai constaté que le Parti
communiste français et le Parti
socialiste était des solidarités moi je
pense qu'on peut saluer cette cette
responsabilité du Parti socialiste et du
Parti communiste parce qu'on savait que
ça allait mal se terminer et que
évidemment slogans avec unlic une balle
suicidez-vous c'est parfois ce qu'on dit
dans les manifestations parce que les
mêmes parlementaires parfois nous posent
des questions sur le malaise dans la
police nationale et et les manestation
auxquell il participe parfois on dit
suicidez-vous au policiers qui qui
encadrent les policiers gendarmes ils
sont quand même plutôt plein d'honneur
on vrait plutôt les remercier ils
encadrent des manifestations de gens qui
ne les aiment pas qui les insultent et
qui leur disent suicidez-vous bon c'est
quand même quelque chose qui
psychologiquement en tant que
responsable voilà de de du bien-être des
personnes devrait quand même nous
interroger donc oui je pense qu'il y a
dans l'hyperviolence dans les propos du
leader de la France insomise dans les
propos de certains pas tous il y a des
gens la France à soumise je vais pas
faire une revue de détail mais qui qui
me disent euh voilà qui sont pas
d'accord j'ai vu les propos de Monsieur
Ruffin qui explique à tout le monde en
tout cas aux collègues de Monsieur
bernalicis notamment que voilà la
question elle est plutôt sociale et
économique identitaire et antipolice bon
j'ai entendu beaucoup de propositions
que Monsieur Corbière par exemple a
souvent des propos positifs sur l'tion
de la police d's que c'est un des seuls
des parlementaires de la franceçis qui
vient au commissariat lorsque je me
déplace et moi je remercie parce queil
montre qu'il peut être à la fois très
opposant au gouvernement être exigeant
avec la police nationale Mo ce que je
comprends très très bien et ne pas
partager les propos euh euh excessifs
euh
idominieux et parfois extrêmement
effectivement insultant euh qui qui
déclenche effectivement un certain
nombre me semble-t-il de violence voilà
euh de là est mesuré avec un sénéal je
suis bien incapable de le faire mais en
tout cas c'est sûr que ça crée une
atmosphère euh qui qui qui est propre me
semble-t-il au non au non resp des des
des forces de l'ordre donc je rappelle
d'ailleurs que ça c'est assez
intéressant euh il y a d'abord une
longue tradition de gauche de soutien à
la police nationale gendarmerie
nationale faut pas l'oublier euh il y a
eu un de grands courants humanistes dans
la police nationale et dans la
gendarmerie nationale il y a
eu de de grandes avancées pour les
droits et et pour une certaine forme de
police je pense bien sûr à Monsieur Jox
monsieur Chevénement monsieur casen fait
partie de cette tradition de soutien à
l'ordre sans pour autant évidemment
accepter des dérives de contestations
des décisions de de justice ou de
fonction ement
euh donc moi je confonds pas la gauche
euh dont une partie d'ailleurs la
sociologie des policiers des gendarmes
fait culturellement partie avec des
propos excessifs
ignominieux d'une partie pas tous
d'ailleurs de la France de la France
insoumise et d'autres mouvement de
gauche ou d'extrême gauche donc je pense
que là il a une discordance intéressante
mais
mais c'est sûr
que le fait de pas voir que les
policiers les gendarmes c'est souvent
les enfants du peuple les gens qui
gagnent entre 2000 et 3000 € par mois
euh dans des conditions de logement
difficiles qui subissent beaucoup de
pression euh de la société beaucoup
beaucoup confrontation avec beaucoup de
misère c'est pas les enfants du du
départron du 440 qui sont policiers hein
c'est c'est c'est c'est unee exception
ce sont les enfants des petits
fonctionnaires des des des artisans des
commerçants euh c'est eux qui font les
les policiers c'est souvent des gens
jeunes quand j'entends une différence
entre jeunesse et police je suis
toujours un peu étonné parce que vous le
savez bien allons voir ensemble des
écoles de police vous verrez des des
gens de 18 19 20 21 ans qui choisissent
le service de la police naationale de
gendarmerie euh je je pense que là il y
a quelque chose de pour une partie me
semble-t-il de la police de la
gendarmerie qui vient des couches
populaires et qui vient d'une d'une sans
doute d'une impétence à l'idéal de la
gauche ils ont pas choisi le profit
quand ils rentrent dans la police
nationale he je pense qu' ils sont pas
défendent pas à priorie l'ordre
capitalistique la financierisution du
monde c'est pas l'option pris par le
gardien de la paix qui est à tourcoinin
je pense qu'il est plutôt
attaché à au service public euh dans des
conditions on la dit difficiles je pense
que là il y a une forme de trahison
sentie par par par ces public là euh qui
qui
renforce ce que je vous disiez sur
l'appel à la violence c'estd que je
pense qu'il y a une double violence dans
le discours d'une partie de la France
insommise il y a une violence contre les
policiers systémique comme on dit
maintenant et qui peut engager des gens
à être violents contre les policiers
parce que il tuerait parce que il serait
meurtrier parce queil ferait des
violences euh à ne pas voir qu'il y a
pas de groupes mais qu'il y en a qu'un
et après il y a des délinquants puis il
y a des gens qui sont pas délinquants
qui sont des policiers et surtout il y a
une violence interne extrêmement forte
de gens qui se disent en fait on est
trahi par des représentants que parfois
on protège je constate d'ailleurs que
dès qu'il y a des menaces dès qu'il y a
des violences physiques les gendarmes et
policiers sont les premiers à accueillir
tous les élus bien évidemment de les
accompagner de faire les enquêtes et et
d'y travailler et c'est tout à fait
normal et c'est normal de le faire
donc je pense que cette violence elle
est double et qu'elle peut déclencher un
certain nombre de de difficultés de
difficultés personnelles pour les
policiers gendarmes parce que c'est pas
drôle de dire à ses enfants regardent à
la télé on dit que tu tues papa c'est
c'est un truc difficile à faire c'est
que les policiers gendarmes aujourd'hui
ils mettent pas toujours sur les Carn de
correspondance des parents leur métier
parce que voilà on a créé ce halo de
suspiss autour d'eux même si l'immense
majorité des Français vous l' encore vu
75 % des Français font confiance à leur
police bien évidemment et il y a une
violence qui peut être effectivement
désinhibée lorsce que des responsables
politiques Appell à la violence appelle
à des manifestations violentes sur les
parlementaires non j'ai pas grandchose à
dire ce sur le fait que je je
m'interroge toujours moi sur des gens
qui joue le jeu
démocratique se présente aux élections
comprennent le le fonctionnement de
notre pays connaissent ce rapport de
force et tout le monde voit bien que bah
oui ils ont perdu les élections et c'est
pas grave et un jour peut-être qu'ils
les gagneront et c'est la démocratie
c'est l'alternance ils n'ont pas le
courage et l'honneur de François
mitteran d'attendre 23 ans manifestement
dans l'opposition pour pouvoir un jour
être en responsabilité et al c'est très
bien fait de le pays puisque du coup bah
ceux qui étaai en majorité ils ont
accepté dans l'pposition et puis voilà
monsieur mitéran a pu appliquer son
programme non l'idée c'est que il
n'accepte pas le jeu démocratique
finalement a refusé les décisions
démocratiques dans lequel ils se sont
inscrites moi que des parlementaires
aillent manifester malgré l'interdiction
faite par la préfette confirmée par un
juge que la préfette très courageuse
Prenn contact avec eux pour all
expliquer que les choses seront
violentes et manifestant malgré tout
dans ces manifestations ou d'ailleurs
ils sont parfois pris à parti on a vu
des scènes étonnantes notamment à
saintseline il y a il y a un nouveau
sénateur là qui a été pris à parti par
un groupe de manifestants qui reprocher
les sénateurs d'être venu alors qu'il
venaent pour dénoncer effectivement ce
que faisit le gouvernement donc je pense
qu'il y a des luttes internes de rapport
de force très compliqué à l'intérieur de
ce qui conteste ce qui sans doute
explique parfois la la recrudescence de
la violence ou des propos ou des
contestations j'ai vu les propos tout à
fait excessifs de Madame Tondelier pas
grand chose à à dire sur ça bien
évidemment madame Tondelier qui était en
contact avec mon cabinet qui est en
contact avec la préfette d'ailleurs le
nit pas bon donc je vais pas rentrer
dans ce détail mais si vous voir des
parlementaires qui en écharpe malgré
tout ça viennent aux manifestations qui
est interdite euh la préfettete leur
disant la préfète dont on ne peut pas
soupçonner quel est son bord politique
elle fait son travail de fonctionnaire
pas plus pas moi hein leur disant
attention ça va être violent les les
avertissant que ça va être violent les
décisions de justice confirmant ce que
disant madame la préfète et venir en
écharpe alors que chacun voit que c'est
une scène quasi de guerre au contact des
boucliers des gendarmes euh avec
quelqu'un qui filme derrière je je suis
toujours circonspect devant ça voilà
après je pense que je suis démocrate les
électeurs choisissent leurs
représentants ils verront ça et aux
prochaines élections les gens sont élus
ou pas réélus mais je suis toujours
circonspect de voir que les gens qui
rentrent dans un jeu démocratique
refusent finalement les règles du jeu
quand ils
perdent
monsieur Mathieu je
vous je vous en
prie Monsieur Mathieu je vous en
prie non vous ne souhaitez pas vous
exprimer maie je vous en prie je vous en
prie merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci d'avoir
rappelé abondamment la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et je
veux bien que vous êtes un amoureux
d'histoire je me permettrai euh de de
rappeler mais je suis sûr que vous
l'ignorez pas que la déclaration des
droit de M dit citoyen est l'enfant
d'une longue suite d'illégalité
particulièrement grave commise à
l'époque a commencé par la prise de la
Bastille qui était légitime mais
illégale a commencé par la désobéissance
au roi qui était qui était légitime mais
illégale d'ailleurs vous-même à chaque
fois que vous venez en QAG vous passez
devant cette magnifique sculpture où nos
illustres Pr